thomas wiegold war dass er ist
journalist und der militärexperte ganz
herzlichen dank
ja und ich gebe jetzt ab nach berlin von
daraus wählen wir den ganzen tag live
übertragen aus dem bundestag wie sie es
bei phoenix gewohnt sind unter anderem
wir haben es eben gehört stellt die
wehrbeauftragte ihren jahresbericht vor
gerd joachim von fallois wird sie
begleiten
vielen dank guten morgen meine damen und
herren die wehrbeauftragte eva högl
stellt ihren jahresbericht vor und
dieser bericht gibt den stand der
bundeswehr aus dem jahre 2021 wieder die
verhöre kommt darin zum schluss dass die
streitkräfte dringend modernisiert
werden müssen es fehlt an vielem zb an
persönlicher schutzausrüstung die
hauptwaffensysteme sind teilweise nicht
einsetzbar und die infrastruktur teils
völlig marode da ist es gut dass der
bundeskanzler eine zeitenwende
ausgerufen hat und mit den 100
milliarden die der bundeswehr zur
verfügung gestellt werden sollen da
lässt sich sicherlich das eine oder
andere machen aber eins muss man auch
festhalten im moment wäre die bundeswehr
sicherlich nur bedingt einsatzfähig wenn
es darum ginge dieses land zu
verteidigen und darüber will ich
sprechen heute morgen mit meinen beiden
gästen wenn ich begrüße wolfgang
hellmich und ali al alami das sind die
beiden verteilungspolitischen sprecher
der spd und der linken
helmig fangen wir mit ihnen an also ich
habe es gesagt viele mängel das ist so
üblich beim wehrbericht diesmal guckt
man besonders darauf aufgrund auf der
aktuellen situation
und wenn frau hügel ihre kolleginnen die
ehemals aus dem bundestag festgestellt
dass bundeswehrsoldaten sogar noch
nichtmals schutzausrüstung haben und
teilweise in den einsatz solcher
ausrüstungen nachgeschickt werden da
muss man schon fragen die bundeswehr ist
eine parlamentsarmee
das sind unhaltbare zustände was werden
sie dagegen tun
also die zustände sind nicht neu und wir
arbeiten würden denen ja schon seit
einigen jahren deshalb ist ja im laufe
der letzten jahre bis jetzt auf 50,3
milliarden der einzelplan 14 der
verteidigungshaushalt auch gestiegen um
genau an diesen stellen auch mit
beschleunigung daran zu gehen die
bundeswehr ausrüstet so können auch die
vorherigen wehrbeauftragten den finger
daher schon nennen die wunde gelegt
damit wir das schneller werden und damit
vor allem die soldatinnen soldaten das
material das sie brauchen auch bekommen
und es hat nicht nur geld rein tun
sondern wir müssen auch die prozesse
beschleunigen in denen in der
beschaffung dann in sehr langen
abständen eben schutzausrüstung zb bis
20 31 beschafft werden sollte das geht
so natürlich nicht und mit diesen 100
milliarden 100 schneller machen aber er
muss noch die prozesse beschrieben also
die bürokratischen fragen müssen
angegangen werden das sind
kommunizierende röhren da muss dem koran
und den ministerien tut das
wenn wir mal drauf schauen die frau
hügel hat auch gesagt 77 prozent
ungefähr ist die bundeswehr einsatzfähig
fand das sogar einen relativ hohen wert
wäre den die bundeswehr ihrer meinung
nach in der aktuellen lage in der lage
unser land zu verteidigen naja frau übel
hat auch einmal gesagt dass die
bundeswehr einsatzbereit ist ich glaube
zunächst einmal die feststellung im
wehrbericht zeigen eklatante lücken auf
das muss man einfach feststellen
hellmich hatte ja schon richtigerweise
darauf hingewiesen dass diese nicht neu
sind ich will aber trotzdem konstatieren
dass wir nicht glauben dass 100
milliarden einfach ich sag jetzt mal in
das schwarze loch im etat die situation
maßgeblich verändern werden ich bin nur
einige beispiele nennen wir haben den
haushalt dem meter verdoppelt in den
letzten 20 jahren trotzdem ist es so
dass die beschaffung nicht funktioniert
und wenn sie funktioniert dann in einem
maßstab der nicht modernistisch wort
funkgeräte die bundeswehr die
soldatinnen und soldaten arbeiten mit
funkgeräten aus den 80er jahren und
anstatt neue modelle zu beschaffen hat
man einfach 30.000 nachbildungen
organisiert gefechts helme sind immer
noch nicht flächendeckend vergeben
schutzausrüstung müssen soldatinnen und
soldaten selber kaufen all das sind
probleme die trotzdem bestehen trotz der
verdopplung des veritas in den letzten
20 jahren deshalb meinen wir 100
milliarden werden dass substanzielle
probleme lösen wir müssen an die
ursachen gehen und das ist das
beschaffungswesen und das ist die art
wie hier mit den geldern umgegangen wird
aber er hält mich woran liegt das dass
das die verschiedenen
verteidigungsminister und ministerin
nicht in den griff kriegen die probleme
sind ja seit eigentlich jahrzehnten
wir haben zu lange und zu komplizierte
prozesse sehr bürokratisch aufgebaut
und haben möglichkeiten die es gibt in
der vergangenheit nicht genutzt ich
nehme ein beispiel aus rahmenverträgen
geld abzurufen und damit sehr schnell ob
beschaffung auszulösen oder die
möglichkeiten des europäischen rechts zu
nutzen den § 346 in den details die
möglichkeiten zu nutzen um auch direkt
selbst beschaffen zu können zum beispiel
keine ausschreibung machen zu müssen
wenn es diesen bedarf der bundes ergibt
darauf wurde in der vergangenheit
verzichtet
jetzt wird dieses instrumente eingepackt
und wie gesagt tempo drauf zu bringen
weil das ziel ist am ende schneller die
dinge offen hof im hafen und männer
stehen zu haben und nicht in welchen
prozessen zu sein man muss da ein satz
zu sagen die bundeswehr ist mit
260.000 menschen der größte arbeitgeber
der bundesrepublik
das ist eine große menge an menschen die
ausgerüstet werden müssen und das ist
auch eine große menge an menschen die
zum geld kosten deshalb sind die mehr im
weg da in den letzten jahren auch in
diesem haushalt aufgefressen worden
seien die kosten für die erhaltung des
alten materials
deshalb ist es richtig in neuss zu
investieren als in altes immer weiter
reinzustecken was aber auch die aufgaben
erfüllt
das bundesamt für wehrtechnik in koblenz
6500 bundeswehr beamte andere beamte die
dort alles verwalten
eine anschaffung über 1000 euro und
aufwärts muss dort verwaltet werden
warum bekommt man das sich hin griff
muss das nicht radikal reformiert werden
das ist absolut radikal reformiert
werden weil das problem ist wie sie
selbst ja vorhin festgestellt haben seit
jahrzehnten bekannt und das problem ist
wie gesagt nicht neu und führt natürlich
dazu dass wir immer größeres traktions
grad auch bei den soldatinnen und
soldaten bekommen das müssen wir doch
auch feststellen wir sind eine
parlamentsarmee und wir haben die
verantwortung dafür sorge zu tragen dass
die soldatinnen und soldaten so gut
ausgerüstet sind wie sie wie möglich und
das ist de facto nicht der fall und das
habe ich schon erwähnt an welchen fällen
dass das haupt aber es hat auch damit zu
tun dass wir aufträge vergeben dieser
kurios anmuten ist nur das beispiel
heckler & koch liefert für über 250
millionen euro sturmgewehre die sich
gerade ausschließen und thekla und koch
muss dafür nicht geradestehen weil die
verträge so ausgestaltet worden sind
dass sie aus der haftung entlassen
worden sind und lastet eklatante
probleme und darüber müssen wir offen
reden und das hat nichts damit zu tun
dass wir irgendwie gegen die soldaten
und soldaten sind wir darüber offen
redet will dass sich die verhältnisse
verändern und die soldatinnen und
soldaten die bestmögliche ausrüstung
ausrüstung bekommen richtig weil es
gerade eine parlamentsarmee ist das ist
ja auch im interesse natürlich der
abgeordneten jetzt ist ja noch schlimmer
herr hellmich das in internationalen
einsätzen die bundeswehrsoldaten
teilweise klar wie die trottel
darstellen zb im baltikum hat frau
hatten bei spielen dann vom letzten jahr
das ist noch nicht von diesem jahr da
sind wir sogar truppenführer quasi und
unsere soldaten können mit den dortigen
funkgeräten nicht umgehen das ist doch
zutiefst peinlich
weil das carlo gekommen ist wir haben
funkel beschafft um im einsatz der nato
mit unseren bündnispartnern
kommunizieren zu können weil die sind
nicht alle durch digitalisiert hätten
wir diese nicht gekauft hätten wir in
den einsätzen gar nicht miteinander
kommunizieren können und deshalb wählen
ihr jetzt diese systeme die alten
gemeinsam in der nato gilt digitale
systeme abgelöst und deshalb muss man
immer noch sagen wir arbeiten den
kontext der nato wir entwickeln das mit
unserer bündnispartner die uns auch
aufgaben in einer zu schreiben was wir
zu liefern was wir zu tun haben deshalb
wollen wir dass eine beispiel dass der
sogenannte haben aufgreifen mit den
ausschreibungen oder verwaltung 1000
euro jetzt sitzen wir diesen diese summe
auf 5000 euro rauf da meint man ist ja
nicht viel aber das bundesamt in koblenz
und ich sag mal die machen eine gute
arbeit das darf ich kann zwar verdacht
aufkommen lassen die haben aber jedes
jahr 3300 beschaffungsprozesse von klein
bis groß und dadurch dass wir diese
summe rauch setzen setzen wir einen
erheblichen teil auch an arbeitskraft
frei die sich dann nicht mehr mit dem
klein-klein befassen müssen sondern dann
in den großen projekten da ans werk
gehen können weil das bundesamt in
koblenz ist personell unterbesetzt und
da muss man an diesen stellen diesen
eckpunkten glaub anpacken und das tut
das bundesamt das tut auch das
ministerium unter wie gesagt mit dem
voranzubringen
als ich zur bundeswehr muss den 80er
jahren da war die bundeswehr noch eine
armee für die landesverteidigung dann
ist es mehrfach nach der
wiedervereinigung geändert worden und
viele sagen es fehlt so eine strategie
gerade im moment fragt man natürlich was
kann die bundeswehr eigentlich könnte
sie uns verteidigen gleichzeitig stehen
wir in mehreren auslandseinsätzen
übernehmen wir uns nicht auch mit der
truppenstärke die wir haben und auch mit
denen intakten waffen denn das ist ja
eine katastrophe wie vor groß gerät
nicht funktioniert das tun wir natürlich
und das sehen wir auch an den
auslandseinsätzen die stattfinden wie
hitler tank die lücken dort sind und wie
problematisch ist diese einsätze
gestalten ich glaube es hängt
miteinander zusammen ein band eine
beendigung der auslandseinsätze ist die
grundlage dafür dass die bundeswehr
überhaupt im kern ihres auftrages
wahrnimmt und dass es die
landesverteidigung ich lehne diese
auslandseinsätze ab stichwort jetzt mali
wo wir derzeit sind und wo die
bundeswehr im einsatz ist diese einsätze
sind einfach gescheitert wir sind im
schlepptau frankreichs dorthin gegangen
wie damals im schlepptau der usa in
afghanistan in afghanistan zogen sich
die usa zurück die bundesregierung stand
da dasselbe erleben wir jetzt mit
frankreichs sie ziehen sich aus mali
zurück und die unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten stehen jetzt einfach auch da
und die bundesregierung hat keinen plan
und deshalb sagen wir raus aus den
auslandseinsätzen kann centra zion auf
die landesverteidigung und die
bestmögliche ausrüstung dafür für die
soldatinnen und soldaten
wäre das nicht eine klare ansage für die
bundeswehr frau lamprecht die neue
verteilt ministerin hat mehrfach auf
fragen gesagt also sie will keine große
reform angehen sondern mehr kleine
schritte an kleineren stellen reparieren
ist das das richtige vorgehen also es
gab mal ein bundesminister der
verteidigung
der hat im plenarsaal gestanden sagte
während an der bundeswehrreform jeden
dienstposten einmal angefasst und
mehrzad aber wenn ich in meinem
unternehmen jeder arbeitsplatz einmal
verändern würde wenn man unternehmen
kaputt
und deshalb war diese reform die dort
angegangen worden ist wie folgt vor
zuende vollzogen ist letztendlich das
auflösen von funktionierenden strukturen
in der bundeswehr
eine große strukturen haben eine große
bedeutet dass die bundeswehr sich über
jahre mit strukturreform prozessen
beschäftigt und befasst das braucht sie
nicht sondern sie muss sich darauf
ausrichten das zu tun was von mir
verlangt wird
ein bisschen im ausland afghanistan sind
wir maßlos gescheitert andere auch sie
ist eigentlich nicht in der lage zur
landesverteidigung es gibt keine vbk es
mehr wie das früher der fall war also im
land es ist doch nicht genau zu erkennen
wenn man sich nicht täglich damit
beschäftigt dafür steht diese bundeswehr
wir brauchen noch kann der neuen
verwaltungsstrukturen aber wir haben das
ziel im jahr 2025 eine voll
digitalisierte division der nato auch
bei der übernahme der edf zur verfügung
zu stellen nicht 20 27 sondern
vorgezogen auf 20 25
das material das das personal das heißt
digital kommunizieren und funken können
das sind neue satelliten technologie die
materielle ausrüstung die
schutzausrüstung und dieses alles gehört
dazu dass er auf das ergebnis kommt es
an und nicht auf ellenlange prozesse und
das ergebnis erzielt werden zb diese
voll ausgestattete die vision 2025
allawi ist ja kein
geheimnis dass ihre fraktionen gegen
diese 100 milliarden sind ihnen das
werden wir sicherlich auch gleich wieder
in den reden hören aber wenn man
tatsächlich mal den ausrüstungsstand der
bundeswehr anguckt und sie haben gerade
gesagt die bundeswehr sollte sich auf
ihren kernauftrag konzentrieren viele in
diesem land zweifeln daran dass die
deutsche bundeswehr zum beispiel einen
russischen angriff zurückschlagen könnte
wie kann man dann verantworten dass man
sagt die bundeswehr hat ja jetzt schon
viel geld die braucht nicht mehr geld
auch wenn geld weg sichert und diese wir
haben ja über koblenz schon gesprochen
dass er sicherlich ein problem ist also
keiner der regierungsvertreter konnte
mir bisher sagen warum es frankreich mit
ähnlichem militär gelingt ja eine gut
ausgerüstete ausgestattete armee zu
haben die diese probleme die wir kennen
in dieser form überhaupt nicht bekannt
ist dass zum ersten zum zweiten ist es
so die letzten jahrzehnte sind geld da
dort schon rhein geflossen wir reden ja
immer über jährliche haushaltsbudgets
von über 50 milliarden jetzt und spieß
einfach mal konkret machen wenn wir
jetzt die 100 milliarden dazunehmen
übrigen gibt es dann demokratiedefizit
weil das an dem haushalt des
verteidigungsausschusses verweigert die
beschaffung also die atombombe wurden
nicht im haushaltsausschuss gestern
beschlossen dass das ein
demokratiedefizit welches ist sie es
will aber sagen dass wären theoretisch
20 milliarden jährlich zusätzlich aus
diesen 100 milliarden topf wir werden
also bei über 70 milliarden wir wären
also der zweitgrößte hätten das
zweitgrößte militärischer der welt wir
hatten in europa dem grössten militär
etat und ich finde das ist
überdimensioniert nicht verhältnismäßig
und noch mal das geld ist da es wird
wirklich nicht ordentlich eingesetzt und
über 50 milliarden sollen nicht dafür
ausreichend über jahre übrigens immer
wieder dass die bundeswehr gut
ausgestattetes ist sage das macht
deutlich dass es eklatante fehler gibt
die man mit mehr geld nicht lösen wird
da ist ja was dran die israelische armee
zum beispiel hat prozentual gesehen viel
weniger geld zur verfügung als dass die
bundeswehr jetzt schon hat und sie ist
trotzdem hoch effizient woran liegt das
herr hellmich sie ist weniger sie ist
wesentlich kleiner
deswegen oder andere punkt weil sie
sagen prozentual sich verfügt auch in
der breite nicht über die fähigkeiten
über die liefer führen hier unterhalten
ganz amos arsenal- auch von fähigkeiten
an der armee die israelische armee ist
auch diese auseinandersetzung
in ihrem land mit ihren nachbarn
ausgerichtet wir sind wesentlichen
weiterhin anbieten das aufgestellt haben
ist in diesen mehr fähigkeiten
unterhalten und auch in den nato
anliefern und deshalb sind die relation
bei uns auch was die waffensystem angeht
andere bleiben sie sind um
verteidigungspolitiker bei der linken
aber wenn man nicht
verteidigungspolitikern der linken
spricht dann sagen die weg mit dem
ganzen geld eigentlich brauchen wir auch
keine bundeswehr und sie sagen ja auch
sehr häufig also jetzt in dem konflikt
um gottes willen wir müssen verhandelt
berufs keine waffen dahin geben wie soll
das funktionieren wollen sie ein putin
am grünen tisch überreden kommen das mal
deine waffen das sind zwei paar schuhe
also programmatisch sind wir für eine
verteidigungsarmee dass die bundeswehr
ihren auftrag erfüllt natürlich in der
pluralistischen partei wie in der
anderen gibt es auch dort andere
positionen und die nehme ich zur
kenntnis dass waffenlieferungen angeht
ich befürchte dass je weiter wir diese
eskalationsspirale mitmachen und nichts
anderes ist ja schwere waffen zu liefern
umso eher kommen wir in die situation
über jahre einen dauernden abnutzungs
und stellungskrieg in europa zu bekommen
uns bleibt doch auf lange ist es doch
nichts übrig mit normalen
menschenverstand als irgendwann doch
miteinander zu reden und zu verhandeln
um irgendwie die waffen zum stillstand
zu bringen und um wieder im verhandlungs
modus zu bekommen und es wurde ja
vorhanden zwischen der ukraine und
russland jetzt ist es wieder ab
ausgesetzt worden also wir müssen wie es
stimmt auch aus der historischen
erwägungen alles dafür tun dass wir zum
frieden kommen zum dialog und zur
entspannung und nicht weiter waffen in
eskalationsspirale schieben die jetzt
schon laufen vielen dank herr al dailami
hellmich dass sie bei uns waren drin
geht es schon los bärbel bas ist nämlich
schon gekommen und hat die öffnung
sitzung eröffnet pardon so rum und ich
gebe rein und wir sind mal gespannt auf
die heutige debatte
die gestern als tagesordnungspunkt 9
beratenden drucksachen
1504 soll
zusätzlich zum finanzausschuss dem
ausschuss für gesundheit und dem
ausschuss für bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
zur mit beratung überwiesen werden ich
sehe hier keinen widerspruch
dann ist das so beschlossen und
jetzt sehe ich gerade dass wir heute ein
besonderes geburtstagskind hier im saal
haben ich will das mal kurz erklären
normalerweise gratulieren wir erst ab
einem runden geburtstag von 50
das trifft auf den kollegen johannes
vogel nicht zu das will ich direkt sagen
gratulieren aber im namen des hauses
ganz herzlich zu ihrem runden geburtstag
heute 40 sind sie geworden herzlichen
glückwunsch
und damit können wir jetzt in die
tagesordnung einsteigen und ich rufe auf
den tagesordnungspunkt 20 beratung des
jahresberichts
2021 der wehrbeauftragten
und für die aussprache wurde eine dauer
von 68 minuten beschlossen
das wort hat zunächst die
wehrbeauftragte des deutschen
bundestages
frau dr eva högl
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren abgeordnete
der entsetzliche krieg in der ukraine
verändert alles für die soldatinnen und
soldaten bedeutet es dass es ernst
werden kann dass es schnell gehen muss
und dass sie immer einsatzbereit sein
müssen die bündnisse und
landesverteidigung die seit 2014 höchste
priorität hat wird jetzt sehr konkret
und unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
reagieren darauf mit hoher
professionalität und mit großer
ernsthaftigkeit und
zudem wird deutlich wofür wir die
bundeswehr haben und warum wir sie
brauchen unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
verteidigen frieden freiheit demokratie
und sicherheit und deswegen sage ich
ganz herzlich dankeschön
184.000 soldatinnen und soldaten die
jeden tag hoch motiviert engagiert
pflichtbewusst ihren dienst leisten
der jahresbericht enthält immer das ganz
für soldaten geben von ausbildung bis
zulagen ich habe im jahresbericht 2021
auch neue themen beschrieben nämlich den
klimawandel und das thema sport denn
auch beim klimawandel trägt die
bundeswehr eine ganze menge dazu bei sie
ist in bereichen auch vorreiterinnen und
sport beschäftigt die bundeswehr nicht
nur im jahr der olympischen spiele
sondern auch jeden tag und dann gibt es
auch noch viel zu tun der jahresbericht
listet immer mängel fehler versäumnisse
auf und im besten fall ist er eine
grundlage für verbesserungen die das
ministerium auf den weg bringt und
natürlich der deutsche bundestag ich
habe mir aber auch vorgenommen und das
ist auch in diesem jahresbericht wieder
der fall gute beispiele aufzuzählen
dinge zu erwähnen auf die wir stolz sein
können die erreicht wurden und die auf
gutem weg sind
wir bearbeiten wir im amt der
wehrbeauftragten im jahr 4000 vorgänge
im jahr 2021 waren das
2606 individuelle eingaben von
soldatinnen und soldaten
ich habe 60 truppenbesuche absolvieren
können und ich bin wirklich dankbar dass
sich trotz corona viele gespräche führen
konnte und dass ich 2021 auch endlich
endlich endlich in die einsatzgebiete
reisen konnte nach litauen nach mali und
niger
und ich bin gerade erst in jordanien und
im irak gewesen und an dieser stelle
lieber abgeordnete möchte ich ganz
herzlich dem amt der beauftragten danken
64 kolleginnen und kollegen bearbeiten
die anliegen der soldatinnen und
soldaten mit erfahrung mit sorgfalt mit
engagement und mit viel herzblut und 6
der kolleginnen und kollegen sind heute
hier und ihnen danke stellvertretend
ich habe gesagt 2021 war das jahr der
bundeswehr denn die truppe hat gezeigt
was sie kann bei der amtshilfe oder beim
ende des afghanistan-einsatzes die
bundeswehr war da wo sie gebraucht wurde
professionell und zuverlässig und die
bundeswehr ist jetzt so gefordert wie
nie und deshalb brauchen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten beste
rahmenbedingungen
das betrifft material personal und
infrastruktur und ich begrüße deshalb
ausdrücklich das geplante 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen und die erhöhung des
verteidigungshaushaltes das sind in
schweren zeiten gute nachrichten für die
touristik
diese mittel sollen genutzt werden um
die volle einsatzbereitschaft wieder
herzustellen damit kann finanziert
werden was in der bundeswehr dringend
benötigt wird und ich sage ganz deutlich
priorität sollte vor allem die
persönliche ausstattung seien helme
schutzwesten bekleidung rucksäcke und
ich freue mich deshalb dass der
bundestag dafür bereits 2,4 milliarden
euro bereitstellt damit mehr und
schneller geschafft werden kann denn das
geld lieber abgeordnete muss schnell und
vollständig in der gruppe ankomme
und da ziehen müssen
dazu müssen auch die prozesse
beschleunigt werden auch die 100
milliarden euro können nicht in den
hergebrachten verfahren ausgegeben
werden das vergaberecht muss vereinfacht
werden und wir brauchen in der
bundeswehr weniger bürokratie
beim material ist noch einiges zu tun
selbst in den einsätzen ist nicht alles
da was soldatinnen und soldaten für
ihren auftrag brauchen das betrifft die
ausstattung genau so wie das große gerät
und der grundsatz train es soweit von
ausbildung über übung bis zum einsatz
der kann leider nicht gewährleistet sein
und wenn deshalb das große gerät zu 77
prozent einsatzbereit ist im jahr 2021
dann ist das zwar eine kleine
verbesserung über die jahre aber das
reicht noch lange nicht aus und ist noch
nicht genug
altena personal möchte ich positiv
hervorheben dass es gelungen ist trotz
corona und das ist eine wirkliche
leistung der bundeswehr den
personalbestand auf demselben niveau zu
halten 183 1695 soldatinnen und soldaten
und jahr 2021 davon 26.600 sechs frauen
das sind 12,8 5% ich habe das thema
frauen im jahresbericht hervor gehoben
weil wir in der milch 2021 20 jahre
frauen in allen teilen der bundeswehr
hatten das ist ein erfolg
ich verbinde das mit der forderung wir
brauchen mehr frauen in der bundeswehr
12,85 prozent reicht noch nicht aus und
wir brauchen vor allen dingen mehr
frauen in führungspositionen
das ganze thema personalgewinnung
personalentwicklung personalbindung ist
eine enorme aufgabe für die bundeswehr
und deswegen muss die gute angebote
machen sie muss aber auch ein
realistisches bild zeigen denn soldat
soldatin zu sein ist kein normaler job
und darauf muss die personalgewinnung
auch deutlich rücksicht nehmen mich
beschäftigt sehr das thema infrastruktur
wir haben einen investitionsbedarf bis
2034 von 19 milliarden euro und die
bauverwaltungen der bundesländer
schaffen alle zusammen pro jahr eine
milliarde das heißt wir haben einen
gewaltigen investitionsstau und wenn ich
in den kasernen binden dann muss ich
sagen der zustand der unterkunftsgebäude
der sportplätze der schwimmhallen der
truppenküche ist nicht akzeptabel da
muss etwas passieren
2021 stand auch im licht des ende des
afghanistan-einsatzes fast 20 jahre
afghanistan-einsatz 93.000 soldatinnen
und soldaten waren dort im einsatz 59
haben ihr leben verloren viele sind
verwundet an körper und seele
zurückgekommen dieser einsatz hat die
bundeswehr verändert und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass er auf gearbeitet wird
und ich hoffe sehr dass die enquete
kommission bald eingesetzt wird denn die
soldatinnen und soldaten erwarten dass
dass dieser einsatz auf gearbeitet wird
und es ist auch wichtig meine damen und
herren für künftige und laufende
einsätze es muss klar sein mit welchen
zielen geht die bundeswehr in die
einsätze in welchen teilen der welt mit
welchen partnern mit welchen mitteln in
welchem umfang und zu welcher dauer das
wollen die soldatinnen und soldaten
geklärt wissen
ich habe mich seit amtsantritt sehr
intensiv mit dem thema rechtsextremismus
befasst
rechtsextremismus ist eine gefahr in
unserer gesellschaft und deswegen auch
ein thema in der bundeswehr es gibt mehr
fälle von rechtsextremismus ich will
ihnen aber ganz deutlich sagen es gibt
eine gestiegene sensibilität und es gibt
dadurch auch mehr meldungen aus der
truppe ich beobachte ein konsequentes
vorgehen in der bundeswehr und ich habe
auch gute beispiele im jahresbericht zum
beispiel nach den vorgängen in litauen
oder den ereignissen beim wachbataillon
ist zügig gehandelt worden und ich will
ihnen auch sagen dass ich der auffassung
bin dass auch die spezialkräfte des
heeres das ksk in calw auf einem guten
weg ist
corona corona beschäftigt und belastet
die truppe und das stelle ich im
jahresbericht auch da es hat die volle
einsatzbereitschaft der bundeswehr
verzögert auch die vorbereitung der nrf
kräfte und deswegen ist es gut und
richtig dass die amtshilfe jetzt
geändert ist wir hatten
2021 bis zu 19.000 soldatinnen und
soldaten zur hoch-zeit zeitgleich im
einzel für einsatz das war eine
grandiose leistung und wir mögen uns
nicht vorstellen wie das in der pandemie
bekämpfung gewesen wäre ohne die
unterstützung der soldatinnen und
soldaten aber meine damen und herren die
bundeswehr hat andere aufgaben die
amtshilfe ist sowie subsidiär und für
die krise und deswegen ist es gut dass
das jetzt geändert ist
ich ende mit dem thema wahrnehmung in
der gesellschaft es gibt jetzt eine hohe
aufmerksamkeit auf die bundeswehr das
tut den soldatinnen und soldaten gut
aber ich will noch mal sagen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten brauchen
respekt anerkennung wertschätzung und
dank aber sie brauchen vor allen dingen
ganz viel interesse aus der gesellschaft
und auch hier aus dem deutschen
bundestag der bundestag hat
verantwortung für die bundeswehr und
deswegen freue ich mich in der nächsten
zeit auch viele gute beschlüsse und
entscheidungen hier im bundestag zur
stärkung und zur unterstützung unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten herzlichen dank
die vögel die wehrbeauftragte des
deutschen bundestages zeigte sich
dankbar dass der bundestag 24 milliarden
euro genehmigt hatte für die persönliche
schutzausrüstung das ist auch aus ihrer
sicht dass der größte mangel dass die
soldaten ebenso wohl im einsatz wie auch
so nicht genügend schutz persönliche
schutzausrüstung haben neben den vielen
anderen mängeln und insofern begrüßt die
ehemalige spd
die ehemalige spd-abgeordnete sich hier
die einheit milliarden euro die für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt werden
sollen
und jetzt als nächste rednerin kommt die
zuständige
bundesverteidigungsministerium
für einen bericht der die mängel in
unserer bundeswehr klar beim namen nennt
im großen leben klein dafür herzliches
dankeschön wir sind darauf angewiesen
gewesen zu wissen wo es denn wirklich
packt in der truppe brust denn im großen
und im kleinen fehlt und wo wir dann
aber auch gegensteuern können denn nur
der bericht alleine hilft ja nichts
sondern handeln ist gefragt wer denn
leben in der aktuellen situation
wir sehen jeden tag wird die
grausamkeiten des russischen
angriffskrieges gegen die ukraine und
wir können heute noch nicht sagen wie
weit putin seinen großmacht zwar
antreibt und deswegen war es noch nie so
wichtig in der geschichte unseres
wiedervereinigten landes wehrhaft zu
sein und das heißt wir brauchen eine
voll ausgestattete und einsatzbereite
bundeswehr die uns und unsere
bündnispartner schützt und der
jahresbericht hilft uns dabei dieses
ziel zu erreichen
dieser dritte der seit 63 jahresbericht
stellt ganz klar fest die frauen und
männer der bundeswehr haben auch 20 21
ihre leistungsfähigkeit ihre
professionalität und verlässlichkeit
unter beweis gestellt und dafür mit
ihnen unser aller dank und respekt
gleichzeitig aber legt der bericht große
erhebliche probleme offen und er macht
auch sehr deutlich wo diese baustellen
sind es besteht ein massiver
investitionsbedarf von der persönlichen
ausstattung über großgerät bis hin zur
infrastruktur und deswegen ist das 100
milliarden
sondervermögen für unsere bundeswehr so
entscheidend wir sind nach den vielen
jahren des mangels auf diesen booster
dringend angewiesen um die materielle
einsatzbereitschaft schnell und
nachhaltig zu erhöhen eine erste
wichtige und von der werbeauftrag tten
zu recht deutlich angemahnten
verbesserung haben wir bereits auf den
weg gebracht gestatten die gesamte
aktive truppe bis 20 25 mit dem vollen
umfang an persönlicher einsatzbekleidung
und persönlicher schutzausrüstung aus
und damit sechs jahre früher als geplant
das war nämlich erst wird
2031 für die gesamte truppe geplant und
es ist gelungen und da möchte ich ein
herzliches dankeschön auch an die
haushaltspolitiker sagen dass es jetzt
gelungen ist das vorzuziehen und dass
wir alle möglichkeiten genutzt haben bei
den verträgen die bestehen dass
vorzuziehen die berühmt berüchtigte
die berühmt berüchtigte loch koppel in
der truppe verschrien und ein
dauerbrenner in den wer berichten gehört
damit bald endlich der vergangenheit an
und wie gesagt ein großer dank an die
abgeordneten des haushaltsausschusses
ich weiß das war sehr kurzfristig wie
ich mit dieser vorlage in den ausschuss
gegangen bin aber mir war es wichtig
alle möglichkeiten auszunutzen dies
vertraglich gab jetzt schnell zu agieren
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten stehen
im mittelpunkt und für ihre
schutzausrüstung müssen wir entsprechend
handeln
damit haben sie trotz vorläufiger
haushaltsführung und ohne viel papier
diese wichtige verbesserungen möglich
gemacht und sie haben zum ausdruck
gebracht wir tun alles was für den
bestmöglichen schutz und die
bestmögliche ausrüstung unserer
parlaments am bbi nötig ist das ist aber
erst der anfang die drohnen bewaffnung
ist bereits beschlossen und wird
umgesetzt duden f 35 kampfflugzeugen
führen wir vertragsverhandlungen mit
unseren amerikanischen freunden und die
entscheidung für den schweren
transporthubschrauber
steht kurz bevor das macht deutlich dass
schaffen eine bundeswehr die deutlich
leistungsfähiger sein wird als heute und
dafür brauchen wir jetzt das
sondervermögen
meine damen und herren es geht aber
nicht nur um die unterfinanzierung
denn
die alleine steht einer besseren
bundeswehr nicht im wege aber das macht
ja wer bereits wehrbericht auch sehr
deutlich und ich will anhand von zwei
punkten ich bin da sehr dankbar frau
wehrbeauftragte dass sie diese auch so
deutlich angesprochen haben an zwei
punkten deutlich machen was wir auch
verändern müssen und das ist bei liebe
beileibe kein kleinkram bildes von manch
ewig gestrigen so angeführt wird diese
zwei punkte treffen grundlegende werte
und damit den inneren zusammenhalt in
der truppe und machen die entscheiden
über die attraktivität unserer
bundeswehr für guten nachwuchs beides
von grundlegender bedeutung für unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit der erste punkt
ist das thema frauen in der bundeswehr
die wehrbeauftragte hat es beschrieben
seit zwei jahrzehnten stehen ihnen alle
laufbahnen offen dennoch liegt der
anteil der soldatinnen in der truppe bei
nur etwas mehr als zwölf prozent
und es ist klar zu wenig denn vielfalt
in all ihren dimensionen ist nicht nur
eine frage der gerechtigkeit
sie bietet auch einen ganz klaren
praktischen mehrwert in studien zeigen
diverse teams sind leistungsfähiger und
erfolgreicher und diverse arbeitgeber
sind sehr viel gefragte und deswegen
fordern wir auch gezielt weibliche
talente durch entsprechende programme
und wir untersuchen
unser personal management laufend auf
systematische barrieren gerade auch was
frauen in führungspositionen
betrifft und da sind wir auf einem guten
weg sagt aber auch da können wir noch
deutlich besser werden und da werden wir
noch deutlich besser und gleiches gilt
für den zweiten punkt der ebenfalls kein
kleinkram ist und zwar der umgang mit
extremismus insbesondere
rechtsextremismus in der bundeswehr die
anzahl der verdachtsfälle ist 20 21
weiter gestiegen ja das ist ein zeichen
dafür dass das bewusstsein dass die
sensibilität für dieses thema gestiegen
ist vor allem aber es ist auch ein
zeichen dafür
dass es immer noch in unseren reihen zu
viele gibt die die werte mit füßen
treten für die sie ihren eid geschworen
haben und das ist nicht hinnehmbar meine
dramaturg
weder
weder für den dienstherrn noch für die
überwältigende mehrheit der kameradinnen
und kameraden die fest zu unserer
verfassungsordnung stehen und deren
ansehen durch diese vorfälle beschädigt
wird und deswegen ist es nicht
hinnehmbar und wir müssen konsequent
dagegen vorgehen und wir treten allen
nationalistischen rassistischen und
fischen in den entschieden entgegen und
werden das weiter konsequent verfolgen
meine damen und herren die
wehrbeauftragte stellt in ihrem
jahresbericht 20 21 fest unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten garantieren
frieden freiheit und sicherheit
20 21 20 32 damit das auch in zukunft
gilt müssen wir jetzt die notwendigen
voraussetzungen schafften die frauen und
männer in der bundeswehr sind froh die
lehrbeauftragte an ihrer seite zu wissen
sie sind aber auch froh abgeordnete des
bundestages an ihrer seite zu wissen die
bereit sind ihre parlamentsarmee
bestmöglich auszustatten und weil der
entscheidung über das sondervermögen
können sie alle dafür ein klares zeichen
setzen vielen dank
us verteidigerin
christine lambrecht hat den bericht der
wehrbeauftragten gewürdigt auch noch mal
ihre eigene rolle zur sprache gebracht
nämlich das jetzt 2,4 milliarden euro
genehmigt worden sind für den kauf
persönlicher schutzausrüstung das auch
dringend
notwendig frau lambrecht wie es auch
nochmal auf den geringeren zu geringen
anteil der frauen hin es gibt eine quote
bei der bundeswehr 50 prozent im
sanitätsdienst und 15 resttruppe
beide quoten sind nicht erreicht kerstin
4g ist für die cdu so lägen in den
letzten 63 tagen haben wir hier im
bundestag so oft und intensiv über die
bundeswehr gesprochen wie schon lange
nicht mehr
das auch gut so denn wir als
parlamentarier haben unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten gegenüber eine besondere
verantwortung
lippenbekenntnisse und große
ankündigungen reichen nicht taten müssen
sehen
jahr für jahr zeigt der bericht der
wehrbeauftragten schonungslos den ist
zustand der bundeswehr auf hält schwarz
auf weiß fest wie es wirklich um die
truppe steht im bericht frau dr hügel
dient uns allen als wertvolle einordnung
und hierfür danke ich ihnen sowie in
ihrem gesamten team
auf
176 seiten werden viele themen
angerissen zahlreiche davon wie zum
beispiel finanzielle ausstattung der
bundeswehr die ausbaufähige
einsatzbereitschaft und mangelnde
infrastruktur haben wir in den letzten
wochen hier im parlament bereits
intensiv diskutiert die heutige debatte
liebt uns folglich die möglichkeit die
themen anzusprechen welche in der
letzten zeit zu kurz gekommen aber nicht
minder wichtig sind aber
lassen sie mich vorher anmerken auch
wenn die regierungsparteien der union
untätigkeit in den letzten
legislaturperioden vorwerfen die 2015 an
geschwulst angestoßenen trendwenden
zeigen schon länger erste erfolge wir
waren auf einem guten weg und die
weichen wurden richtig gestellt
doch die
sicherheitspolitische rahmen lage hat
sich grundlegend verändert und deshalb
muss dieser kurs nicht nur konsequent
und zielgerichtet weiter verfolgt werden
sondern bedrohungs gerecht intensiviert
werden genau deshalb ist es unerlässlich
dass die bundesregierung die
angekündigte zeitenwende durchzieht und
konsequent umsetzt doch signale aus der
koalition zeichnen ein anderes bild der
zweite regierungsentwurf für den
einzelplan 14
die stagnierende mittelfristige
finanzziele für den selbigen die
infragestellung der zweckgebundenheit
des sondervermögens und letztlich auch
der hacker kurs der regierung bei der
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
sind hierfür nur einige beispiele
selbst ein neutraler beobachter würde
zur schlussfolgerung kommt dass die
zeitenwende leider immer noch nicht in
die kurzen aller kollegen in der
ampelkoalition angekommen ist
es ist immer wieder beeindruckend was
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten aller
geschilderten widrigkeiten zu trotzen
leistet haben und weiterhin tagtäglich
leisten
das engagement unserer bundeswehr war im
berichtsjahr 2021 so vielfältig wie
selten zuvor dazu zählen unter anderem
die erfolgreiche evakuierung von
insgesamt 5.000 347 personen vom kabuler
flughafen über 17 millionen ab
geleistete arbeitsstunden von
soldatinnen und reservistinnen und sowie
soldaten und reservisten im rahmen der
korona amtshilfe sowie die unverzüglich
erfolgten einsätze in dem vom
jahrhunderthochwasser betroffenen dann
flutgebieten in nordrhein westfalen und
rheinland pfalz noch nie war die
bundeswehr so sichtbar wie im
vergangenen jahr erholt hat uns die
bundeswehr bewiesen dass wir uns stets
auf sie verlassen können dies ist auch
in der breiten gesellschaft so
wahrgenommen worden
der krieg in der ukraine und die damit
verbundenen verwerfungen im
sicherheitspolitischen gefühl haben zur
folge dass wir von jedem einzelnen
unserer soldaten in den kommenden jahren
noch mehr verlangen werden müssen als
wir es ohnehin schon tun eine
einsatzbereite und kaltstart fähige
bundeswehr benötigt aber nicht nur
moderne ausstattung und material
besonders in der jetzigen situation
müssen wir alle darauf achten dass wir
die lebenswirklichkeit und die sozialen
belange unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
in unseren parlamentarischen debatten
nicht zu kurz kommen lassen denn auf die
verteidigungspolitik hat eine soziale
dimension
viele mögen soldatin beziehungsweise
soldat nicht einfach nur als beruf
ansehen sondern als berufung unabhängig
von dieser selbst und fremdwahrnehmung
sind unsere frauen und männer in uniform
menschen mit ihrer ganz eigenen
lebenswirklichkeit
ob diese geprägt ist von
lebenspartnerschaften dem eheleben
kindern oder sonst die sonstigen
faktoren spielt eigentlich keine rolle
der dienst in der bundeswehr hat nicht
nur einen prägenden einfluss auf die
lebensumstände jeder soldat in und jedes
soldaten sondern auch auf deren
unmittelbares umfeld und auf angehörige
jedes uniformierte mitglied der
bundeswehr sowie dessen angehörige sind
sich bewusst wie geladen das
spannungsfeld zwischen familie und
dienst ist
die für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung so wichtige
kaltstart fähigkeit wird diese
spannungsfeld noch verstärken
planbare auslandseinsätze die durch eine
lange vorlaufzeit um vorkehrungen für
die eigene abwesenheit ermöglichen sind
eben genau das gegenteil von kalt stadt
fähigkeit hier reden wir über die nicht
planbare kurzfristige mobilisierung und
verlegung von tausenden soldaten auf
unbestimmte zeit mit sehr kurzer
vorwarnzeit
die betreuungs und fürsorge angebote für
angehörige von bundeswehrsoldaten sind
gut aber
nicht im ansatz für solche
größenordnungen ausgelegt
was bedeutet das konkret was bedeutet
das für die offiziere in die zu hause
ihren vater pflegt was bedeutet das für
den feldwebel dessen zwei kinder noch
intensiv betreut werden müssen und erst
eine frau voll berufstätig ist und das
sind nur zwei von rund 184.000
uniformierten bundeswehrangehörigen für
die wir eine antwort haben müssen es
muss
über den materialen aspekt der
einsatzbereitschaft hinaus auch immer
der personelle aspekt der
einsatzbereitschaft mitgedacht werden
dazu gehört nicht nur betreuung und
fürsorge im einsatzland sondern auch für
die im heimatland befindlichen
angehörigen und familien
dies ist keinesfalls nur für den
momentanen personalbestand der
bundeswehr von relevanz sondern wird
sich auch maßgeblich auf die
attraktivität der bundeswehr als
arbeitgeber für das dringend benötigte
neue anzuwerben de personal auswirken
wenn wir mehr von unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten jetzt und in der zukunft
verlangen werden dann ist es unabdingbar
dass wir auch bessere soziale
rahmenbedingungen schaffen in denen sie
ihren dienst entsprechend aussuchen
können
auch aus diesen gründen sind wir als
union davon überzeugt dass eine
nachhaltige und dauerhafte erhöhung des
einzelplan 14
zusätzlich zum sondervermögen dringend
notwendig ist
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
wir müssen in gesamtkonzepten denken das
heißt die weniger offensichtlichen
implikationen des eingeschlagenen weges
zu berücksichtigen und adäquat zu
adressieren vielen dank
[Applaus]
klassen 4 eg war das für die cdu/csu sie
hat hier noch mal untermauert dass neben
dem 100 milliarden
auch der vital in zukunft angehoben
werden muss richtung 2 das ist ja die
haltung der cdu csu da wird sicherlich
hinter den kulissen noch viel diskutiert
werden ehe dann voraussichtlich im juni
dieses 100 milliarden paket und die
grundgesetzänderung verabschiedet werden
kann
spielberg für die bündnisgrünen
bundeswehr haben gerade selber noch
einmal gesagt wie sie es im bericht
geschrieben haben für den 4 danken
möchte und ein jahr das nicht nur für
die gesellschaft sondern eben auch für
die bundeswehr enorme herausforderung
mit sich gebracht hat zum einen kurbelt
die unterstützung der bundeswehr bei der
bekämpfung tempo der pandemie war
außerordentlich der truppe gilt hier
mein großer dank
nun aber soll sich die bundeswehr auch
wieder auf ihren kernauftrag
zurückbesinnen
zum anderen auch das wurde schon
angesprochen afghanistan nach 20 jahren
vor ort haben wir unseren militärischen
einsatz dort beendet auch hier bedanke
ich mich bei allen angehörigen der
bundeswehr die dort eine gute arbeit
geleistet haben die ziele wurden nicht
erreicht aber die verantwortung dafür
liegt in der politik auch in diesem haus
die enquete kommission und deren
verantwortung wurde auch angesprochen
aber
eins 2021 auch gleich geblieben der
bericht der wehrbeauftragten zitiert zum
teil chancen doch ein großer masse ist
es eher eine mängelliste und eine
aufzählung von lippen von fragen und vom
problem
und als abgeordnete ein des landes mit
einer parlamentsarmee sind meine ziele
folgendes eine vollumfängliche
persönliche schutzausrüstung für die
soldaten ein gemessene unterbringung und
versorgung die härteste bekämpfung von
rechtsextremismus und gleichberechtigung
in den streitkräften
und um die herausforderung auf dem weg
dahin deutlich zu machen möchte ich
einige zahlen aus dem bericht hervor
4 7 milliarden euro so viel wurde durch
die letzte bundesregierung im baum und
in sanierungsmaßnahmen verwendet aber
die werbeauftritte bescheinigt den
unterkünften den sanitäreinrichtungen
den truppen küchen und sportplätzen
dennoch endlich zum teil desolate
zustand und bei diesen anlagen liebe
kolleginnen handelt es sich ja nicht um
luxus räume sondern eben die
grundlegendsten einrichtungen für unsere
soldatinnen und
unser ziel ist dass planungs vorgänger
entsprechend zu beschleunigen den bau
neuer und die sanierung alter
einrichtungen eine höhere priorität
zukommt zu machen
und eine weitere sache hat sich nicht
wirklich geändert
beschaffungsprozesse sind unflexibel
langwierig und nicht ausreichend
bedarfsorientiert und dadurch ergeben
sich teilweise extreme defizite in der
materiellen ausstattung der truppe und
wir fordern wie die werbeauftrag das den
soldatinnen gerade aber nicht nur im
einsatz um die bestmöglichste ausrüstung
zusteht und um dem zu entsprechen hat
die jetzige bundesregierung erste
maßnahmen getroffen um diese vernünftige
ausstattung zu gewährleisten zu
ermöglichen und mit dem sondervermögen
wollen wir dies unter anderem fortführen
eine weitere zahl
1501 40 soldatinnen leiden bekannter
weise bis ende letzten jahres unter
einsatz folgen unter körperlichen und
seelischen folgen von ausgangs einsetzen
und hier ist anzuerkennen dass es
bereits fortschritte gab zb durch das
einsatz weiterverwendung gesetz aber
gerade zum beispiel bei der
wiedereingliederung von soldaten den
dienst bleiben weiterhin viele hürden
bestehen und unser ziel ist es auch
darüber hinaus dass jede soldatin jeder
soldat angemessen versorgt und betreut
zur nächsten 2
589 so viele fälle von rechtsextremen
verhalten wurden vom militärischen
abschirmdienst gemeldet und das ist eine
deutliche zunahme auch bei gestiegener
sensibilität und für uns ist ganz klar
der großteil unserer soldatinnen steht
ganz fest auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes sie verteidigen die werte
der verfassung und schützen unsere
freiheit doch die steigende zahl an
rechtsextremen und reis bürger innen ist
mehr als besorgniserregend und noch
immer werden solche fälle von einigen
als einzelfälle abgetan und verharmlost
das kann und darf nicht sein
es braucht weiter eine höhere
sensibilisierung eine bessere prävention
durch gute politische bildung und das
klare bekenntnis zur inneren führung
rechtsextremen haben in der bundeswehr
nichts zu suchen
und zuletzt
2 das ist der prozentuale anteil der
frauen in der bundeswehr auch das wurde
gerade schon angesprochen auch 20 jahre
nach dem urteil des europäischen
gerichtshofs ist die gleichstellung von
frauen und männern noch nicht überall in
den streitkräften selbstverständlich
auch das muss sich ändern
vor zwei tagen haben wir genau hier über
das sondervermögen zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung debattiert es lässt
sich also bereits absehen dass die
bundeswehr auch in diesem jahr in 2022
eine überaus relevante rolle spielen
wird
der krieg in der ukraine und die
veränderte sicherheitslage in europa und
der welt werden auch die bundeswehr
prägt
und das ziel der bundesrepublik bleibt
es in europa und international dazu
beizutragen frieden zu schaffen und dazu
brauchen wir auch sicherheit und genau
dazu kann eben die bundeswehr ihren teil
bei
und jetzt ist es eben an uns als
deutschen bundestag die voraussetzung
weiter dafür zu schaffen dass die
bundeswehr für die krisen von heute aber
eben auch für die krisen von morgen gut
aufgestelltes dankeschön
merle spellerberg hat gerade noch einmal
gesagt wie sie sich eine funktionierende
bundeswehr vorstellt natürlich dass die
soldaten schutzausrüstung haben es wirkt
in diesen tagen ein bisschen
anachronistisch dass man hier diskutiert
die mängel der bundeswehr und es stellt
sich immer die frage ob diese bundeswehr
in der lage wäre einen russischen
angriff abzuwehren hannes genau hat er
war bis zum vergangenen jahr selber
zeitsoldat bei der bundeswehr im eingang
des werberings 20 21 heißt es die
bundeswehr wurde bei der amtshilfe
zeigen was sie können und schon hier
zeigt sich das gute verhältnis der
etablierten politik zur bundeswehr
unsere soldaten sind soldaten sie sind
keine aushilfskräfte für private
dienstleister und keine lückenfüller für
die pflege oder andere sektoren in denen
ihre politik versagt
meine damen und herren es ist die
vielleicht in den letzten wochen wieder
vor augen geführt worden die kernaufgabe
der bundeswehr ist die
landesverteidigung
die truppe beweis nicht beim aushelfen
in fremden bereichen was sie kann
sondern im militärischen regelbetrieb im
täglichen kasernen dienst auf den
zahlreichen übungen ebenso wie im
auslandseinsatz dass sie die bundeswehr
seit ewigkeiten aber eben nicht wie eine
ernst zu nehmende armee behandeln
spiegelt sich auch in diesen werbe
riecht wieder zu wenig material zu wenig
personal veraltete strukturen gleich auf
seite 8 heißt es zitat kein
truppenbesuch und kein gespräch mit
soldatinnen und soldaten in dem wir
nicht von mängeln berichtet wird und
auch ich kann aus meiner aktiven
dienstzeit daraus ausführlich berichten
wir haben in den letzten wochen viel von
großgerät gesprochen doch fangen wir
doch beim elementarsten an bei der
persönlichen ausrüstung des soldaten
fragen sie doch mal einen erfahrenen
mannschaftsdienstgrade oder porto pi und
offizier was dieser so in seiner
dienstzeit an eigenem geld in privat
beschaffte ausrüstung investiert hat
meine damen und herren ich gebe ihnen
brief und siegel sie erhalten als
antwort einen mittleren vierstelligen
betrag und das meine damen und herren
ist beschämend das kann doch nicht der
anspruch einer professionellen armee
seien
zwei beispiele aus der praxis erstens
die dienstlich gelieferten schießen
schuhe sind in der regel zu groß
insbesondere am zeigefinger ist die
passform eine katastrophe und deswegen
schneiden viele soldaten das innenfutter
heraus mit diesen handschuhen ist es für
jeden soldaten nahezu unmöglich morgens
um 7 auf der schießbahn bei minusgraden
das 80 20 verfahren sauber durchführen
zu können für die vaterlands kritischen
kräfte hier aus der linken ecke man
spannt den haaren bei der fest ohne bei
diesem verfahren zu 80 prozent vor und
lässt dann die verbleibenden 20 prozent
den schuss alleine kommen sollte man
wissen es wurden das veraltete noch
koppel system meine damen und herren es
wäre wirklich schön wenn unsere soldaten
sich nicht selbst funktionsfähige kampf
festen oder platten träger besorgen
müssten weil sie auf eintrag konzept
angewiesen sind das älter ist als der
kalte
eine weste mit der man im inland
trainieren kann und mit welcher man
gegebenenfalls in den auslandseinsatz
verlegt das benötigen unsere männer und
frauen bevor man milliarden deutsches
steuergeld für großgerät ausgibt für das
kein konzept vorliegt und wo nicht klar
ist ob diese systeme kompatibel sind und
woher man sie überhaupt nehmen soll
sollte man doch lieber bei der
persönlichen ausrüstung des soldaten
anfang
frau strack-zimmermann da können sie
gerne zwischenrufen ich weiß ihnen
gefällt dass wenn hier ein steiniger und
offizier eine heroische rede hält und
neu ist gerät allein
und neues gerät allein kann den menschen
nicht ersetzen den menschen der für sein
vaterland zu bluten bereit ist bei einem
meiner letzten truppenbesuche stellte
ich an einem kampf material fest dass
nur 60 prozent der feldwebel stellen
besetzt sind meine damen und herren so
kann doch eine armee nicht funktionieren
und als ehemalige personaler sage ich
ihnen jetzt auch woran das liegt die
stellenbesetzung vom bundesamt für
personalmanagement muss wahrheitsgetreu
abgebildet werden was in der praxis
nicht immer der fall ist weiterhin
müssen die einplanen karrierecenter zu
den soldaten ehrlich sein wenn die
meisten feldwebel brechen erst ab
nachdem sie die allgemeine militärischen
lehrgänge sowie ihre fach teile
absolviert haben und nach drei jahren
zum ersten mal in führungsverantwortung
in die kampftruppe kommen man muss die
jungen menschen bereits im
karrierecenter aufklären was sie dort
erwartet die truppe ist nun mal zum
kämpfen da und dazu unser vaterland zu
verteidigen und ja da kann der ton auch
mal rauer sein ist er ähnlich wie hier
wenn sie wenn sie den beruf des soldaten
allerdings nur mit geld anreizen
attraktiv machen wollen dann wird dies
scheitern soll das muss wieder berufung
sein und dafür muss der soldat
gesellschaft gesellschaftlich wieder mit
mehr ehre anstand stärke und status
assoziiert werden aber das ist natürlich
nicht möglich mit einer regierung die
sich gegen die toxische männlichkeit
einsetzt wie sie alle nun in
endlosschleife betont haben zeigt der
krieg in der ukraine dass die
konventionelle landesverteidigung eines
nationalstaates auch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
überlebenswichtig ist schön dass sie
dies nun endlich begriffen haben doch
ihre einsicht erfolgte zu spät das beste
beispiel ist die beschaffung bewaffneter
drohnen damit hätten viele gefallene in
afghanistan verhindert werden können
aber die spd hat sich über etliche jahre
hinweg dagegen gewehrt nach knapp zwei
jahrzehnten kroko und der
auslandseinsätze mit tausenden kameraden
die mit körperlichen und seelischen
verletzungen heimgekehrt sind gibt es
immer noch keine bitterarmen kultur in
der bundesrepublik so als gäbe es
überhaupt keine männer und frauen die
für unser land gekämpft haben ja genau
ganz tschuldigung gestatten sie eine
zwischenfrage oder bemerkung bleibt das
mülheim familien die vater oder mutter
sohn oder tochter bruder oder schwester
verloren haben und vielleicht nie wieder
so zusammenkommen können wie vor dem
krieg die von den ptbs betroffenen
soldaten mit nach hause gebracht haben
keine projekte keine offensiven zur
verbesserung der pflege oder
reintegration der veteranen zurück in
die gesellschaft im wehrbericht dazu
nicht mal eine viertel seite zu gender
und fifa als ideologie hingegen mehrere
seiten auch das sagt eigentlich bereits
alles auf ihre politischen prioritäten
haben nichts mit der verantwortung für
die soldaten zu tun die sie in die
auslandseinsätze schicken meine damen
und herren
das offenbarte sich ganz eindrücklich im
umgang mit dem truppenabzug aus
afghanistan
da heißt es auf seite 15 im wehrbericht
dazu politisch verantwortlichen nahmen
nicht an dem empfang teil weder
vertreterinnen noch vertreter der
bundesregierung noch des deutschen
bundestages das war im nachhinein
betrachtet ein fehler zitat ende und für
die nachträgliche er würdigung unserer
veteran der afghanistan einsätze wird im
wehrbericht was vorgeschlagen frau dr
hügel eine briefmarke mehr nicht das
wäre angeblich ein schönes zeichen des
dankes wer so mit denjenigen umgeht die
für dieses land zu sterben bereit sind
kann einfach keine wertigkeit herstellen
denn das meine damen und herren würde
eine geistig-moralische
patriotische wende bedeuten und das
wissen sie und das fürchten sie wenn wir
als nation noch die wende schaffen
wollen muss das credo lauten weniger
klima gender und kritische theorie mehr
trainiere wie du kämpfst mehr treue und
liebe zum eigenen deutsche tugenden
statt links liberaler werte die mit der
realität einer armee nichts zu tun haben
es braucht eine alternative für die
bundeswehr wo vaterland an erster stelle
steht und nicht vielfalt um ihren preis
vielen dank
hannes genau war das für die ard der
bundestag debattierte im jahresbericht
20 21 der wehrbeauftragte eva högl die
wehrbeauftragte wird als hilfsorgan des
deutschen bundestages bei der
parlamentarischen kontrolle der
streitkräfte berufen und die vögel hat
sogar einen eigenen sitzplatz nämlich
neben der bundesratsbank dort sitzt die
wehrbeauftragte dort wird extra ein
stuhl aufgebaut denn in den meisten
sitzung ist sie hier nicht anwesend
bundestagsabgeordnete war sie mal aber
es
gibt jetzt vom vorschlag zimmermann fdp
eine zwischen nervenzellen
schneidigen unteroffizier oder soll ich
sagen an den schneidigen unteroffizier a
d
vielleicht herr kollege weil sie ja hier
sehr stark aufgetreten sind
beeindruckend ihre fraktion hat ja
gerade genau
können sie mal diesem hohen haus und
damit der öffentlichkeit erklären ich
unterstelle es ihn nicht dass sie keine
uniformen tragen dürfen dass sie nicht
mehr in die kaserne rein dürfen
vielleicht erklären sie das dem hohen
hause dass ein schneidiger unteroffizier
hd den mut hat hier so aufzutreten und
im namen der bundeswehr zu sprechen die
nehme ich dieses land verteidigt sind
sie immer noch dabei oder sind sie nicht
dabei herr unteroffizier schneidig
sehr genau ob sie dürfen wenn sie
möchten antworten
frau schavan vielen dank für die
zwischenfrage dass ich mich hier auch
nochmal erklären kann ich merke hier die
rede hat ihnen gefallen und auch mit
auftreten noch einmal zur klarstellung
dass ag steht natürlich deswegen hinter
meinem dienst gerade weil ich in den
deutschen bundestag gewählt wurde und
nicht weil ich aus der truppe entlassen
wurde es gab eigentlich richtig ist
disziplinarverfahren es gab lediglich
vorermittlungen zwei jahre lang zu einem
gerichtlichen disziplinarverfahren
dieses wurde nie eröffnet deswegen bin
ich immer noch soldat und wurde auch vor
wochen herzlich in meiner alten kaserne
empfangen vielen dank
es gab ein es gab einen zweiten wunsch
einer kurzintervention aus der
spd-fraktion von johannes als
dankeschön lieber herr kollege genau
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte als offizier sagen der 19
jahre im dienst ist der 7 aus eines
hinter sich hat sie sprechen nicht die
bundeswehr
innerhalb mit dem verteidigungsausschuss
und sie haben es gehört offizier der
bundeswehr
genau sie haben das wort wenn sie
antworten nicht
[Musik]
ich glaube wir sollten jetzt alle mal
wieder ein bisschen runterfahren herr
genau kartells das wort
er genau hat jetzt auch das wort und
darf antworten ja er war ja erst mal
vielen dank für ihren langen dienst in
den streitkräften und genau so wie sie
heute gar nicht hier in dieser debatte
sprechen sprechen sie alleine für die
spd fraktion und ich spreche für die afg
fraktion und viele millionen meiner
wähler darauf bin ich sehr stolz und ich
weiß auch wie viele soldaten jetzt
zuschauen und vor dem fernseher
applaudieren danke
wir gehen jetzt weiter in der debatte
und als nächster redner hat das wort
lars lindemann für die fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte frau dr
auch ich möchte ihnen im namen meiner
fraktion für ihre arbeit danken und
bitte sie darum dass auch an ihre
mitarbeiter die heute hier sind
weiterzugeben herzlichen dank für ihre
arbeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
wehrbeauftragte fungiert als mittler
zwischen parlament und der bundeswehr
zum schutz der grundrechte der
soldatinnen und soldaten als hilfsorgan
des deutschen bundestages also von uns
allen bei der parlamentarischen
kontrolle der bundeswehr dabei geht es
ganz wesentlich
in unserem auftrag um die stellung und
funktionalität der bundeswehr in der
verfassungswirklichkeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland über die auf
das jahr 20 21 bezogenen erkenntnis
untersuchungen verhält sich dann auch
der heute debattierte bericht liebe frau
dr
die ihnen übertragene aufgabe ist
ausdruck der ganz besonderen
verantwortung von uns allen hier im haus
gegenüber der bundeswehr für deren
fähigkeiten in der gesamtheit aber auch
für die soldatinnen und soldaten in
ausübung ihres berufes im konkreten
beide dimensionen sprechen sie in ihrem
bericht an sie haben darin
unzulänglichkeiten und auch
unzumutbarkeiten deutlich benannt ob uns
als parlament ist dann immer gelungen
ist auch bei den berichten der
vorgängerinnen und vorgänger immer die
richtigen schlüsse zu ziehen das müssen
wir wohl eingestehen waren nicht immer
der fall aber es geht bei einem solchen
eingeständnis mein lieber herr kollege
von der hfg eben nicht darum dass man
lautstark mit dem finger auf andere
zeigt sondern wir bemühen uns gerade im
parlamentarischen diskus diese
unzulänglichkeiten jetzt zu beseitigen
wissen sie zeichnet in den demokraten
aus dass er wenn er etwas erkennt in der
lage ist daneben auch die notwendigen
konsequenzen zu ziehen nach ihren dummen
gequatsche hier kann ich nicht erkennen
dass sie in der lage sind solche
konsequenzen zu ziehen
aber es kommt etwas anderes hinzu der
vorgelegte bericht bezieht sich auf
einen zeitraum und er entstand in seiner
schriftlichen abfassung noch vor dem
bruch der europäischen friedensordnung
durch einen von russland begonnenen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine seit dem
24 februar bekommen wir alle jeden tag
unsere verletzlichkeit vor augen geführt
und auch die notwendigkeit einer
wehrhaftigkeit unserer demokratie darum
möchte ich nicht auf die im bericht gut
nach lesbaren und detailliert
dargestellten einzelheiten eingehen
meist sind sie auch länger bekannt ich
würde gern liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
etwas anderes hinzufügen deutschland ist
nicht unmittelbare kriegspartei wir
wollen dies weder selbst noch in der
nato als bündnis werden aber der krieg
ist nicht nur geografisch nah er bewegt
und erschüttert uns alle ganz
individuell auf unterschiedliche art und
weise die sichtbaren auswirkungen des
krieges wie zb die ankunft und die
unterbringung von flüchtlingen
das für mich und die überwiegende
mehrheit in diesem land körperlich
spürbare mitleid mit den ukrainischen
volk die verbale durchaus heftige
debatte um die frage und den richtigen
weg ob wir schwere waffen in die ukraine
liefern das ganz individuelle vom
wohlstandsverlust vermied
wohlstandsverlust verbundene aushalten
von auswirkungen der sanktionen hier in
deutschland das alles sind nur zum glück
vorstufen und nicht vergleichbar mit dem
was für für unser land was andere
aushalten müssen wenn es krieg auch für
uns hier geben würde wir alle hoffen
dass dies bei diesen vorstufen bleibt ob
dies tatsächlich so sein wird kann sagen
liebe frau dr höhe ist es darum in ihrem
nächsten bericht und in ihrer arbeit bis
dahin noch viel stärker darauf
einzugehen dass sie begleiten und
kontrollieren und am ende auch
transparenz dafür schaffen ob die von
uns in diesen tagen auf den weg
gebrachten maßnahmen zur ertüchtigung
unserer bundeswehr tatsächlich und ganz
besonders in der wahrnehmung der
soldatinnen und soldaten am anfang der
berichts kette tatsächlich wirksam
werden es geht um unser aller
glaubwürdigkeit dabei gegenüber den
soldatinnen und soldaten und auch
gegenüber unserem land dies ist
notwendig damit unser nun eingeschlagene
weg der beschleunigten und aufwändigen
ertüchtigung der bundeswehr die
akzeptanz hier im parlament aber auch in
der deutschen gesellschaft bereit ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
die der beauftragte des bundes der
bundeswehr so was wie die anwältin der
soldaten im vergangenen jahr gab es 2006
106 persönliche eingaben von soldaten
das waren weniger als im jahre 20 20 und
jetzt gibt es nur ein ordnungsruf
des kollegen genau gehört aus den reihen
der spd-fraktion
und für diesen ausdruck den sie
genannt haben
[Musik]
erteile ich dem das sage ich ihnen jetzt
den kollegen christian petri einen
ordnungsruf es ging um den ausdruck
dummschwätzer
und wir haben uns hier alle vereinbart
dass wir uns hier nicht gegenseitig mit
irgendwelchen titeln beleidigen und
insofern profis die der zuordnung und
damit
kommen wir wieder zur debatte
und als nächstes hat das wort die
kollegen aus der fraktion die linke
jacqueline nazi
also ordnungsruf in die eigene fraktion
von bärbel bas als unparteiische
parlamentspräsidentin gegenüber
christian petry und jetzt also zeigt den
mast xi ist die obfrau der linksfraktion
im verteidigungsausschuss
die fraktion die linke der
beauftragten für den bericht allerdings
wirkte auch im hinblick und in
verbindung mit einigen aussagen der
wehrbeauftragten einige fragen auf die
bundeswehr ist einsatzbereit sagte frau
hügel bei der vorstellung des berichts
und das klingt ja erst mal etwas anders
als das sonst wiederkehrende mantra die
bundeswehr seien schlecht aufgestellt
und hätten nicht genügend geld in den
vergangenen 20 jahren ist der
werbeetat verdoppelt wurden von 26,5 auf
52,8 milliarden wenn also etwas schief
läuft dann liegt das wohl nicht an
mangelnden geld sondern am völligen
missmanagement der politisch
verantwortlichen an schlechten verträgen
und fragen berater verdienen
und deutschland braucht dringend die
hunderten milliarden aber nicht für
weitere aufrüstung sondern für bildung
für gesundheit und gute renten das sind
unsere besten waffen
und frankreich zeigt ja dass es geht
dank raich hat ein innen ähnliches
militärbudget wie deutschland aber da
gibt es kein dauer mantra und
lamentieren über die medien über panzer
die nicht geradeaus fahren und gewehre
die nicht gerade aus schießen also
sollten endlich die politisch
verantwortlichen beginnen gerade
auszudenken und aufhören das geld der
steuerzahlerinnen zu verschwenden
und es mutet doch etwas komisch komisch
an ausgerechnet lobend afghanistan zu
erwähnen dass das kein ruhmesblatt war
liegt weiß gott nicht an den soldatinnen
oder soldaten oder am mangelnden geld
sondern dieser fish tank von beginn an
vom politischen kopf her und einige
diese köpfe sitzen immer noch in diesen
rein
mindestens
285.000 zivilistinnen wurden in
afghanistan grausam ermordet im land
herrscht eine humanitäre katastrophe um
mit den taliban sind die gleichen
machthaber wieder an der macht die
angeblich sonst oft von den in
afghanistan vorher befreit werden sollte
und warum verschleppen sie den
untersuchungsausschuss zu afghanistan
frau hügel hat das ja richtigerweise
angemerkt dass er dringend notwendig ist
und immer also wehrbeauftragte dürfte ja
bekannt sein dass die bundeswehr laut
grundgesetz eine verteidigungsarmee es
stattdessen reden sie aber vom
bündnisverteidigung die nato hat sich
weder in diesen grausamen tagen noch in
den jahren zuvor als ein friedensbündnis
erwiesen also machen sie also machen sie
sich nicht von einer wehrbeauftragten zu
einer werbe beauftragten brüstung
industrie bitte
waren sie bitte den überparteilichen
charakter einer werbeauftrag tten und
vor allen dingen den charakter der
bundeswehr eine parlamentsarmee und
die linke schließt sich ausdrücklich
an diejenigen soldatinnen und soldaten
an die rechtsextremismus nicht in ihren
reihen dulden wollen und meldung
erstatten schade dass es bei der
bundeswehr aber nicht in diesem hohen
hause geht es braucht viel klarere
konsequenzen gegen rechtsextreme auch
unter den reservisten im vergangenen
jahr wurden 1033 sachverhalte mit
extremismus bezug innerhalb der
bundeswehr ermittelt helfen sie dringend
frau hügel dieses aufzuklären wie so
steigen die verdachtsfälle wieso gibt es
so viele radikalisierungen unter den
reservisten und in welcher form werden
die dienstvorgesetzten in die pflicht
genommen
hier ist der bericht leider ziemlich
dumm meine damen und herren trotz des
politischen und des medialen
säbelrasseln haben die ostermärsche
gezeigt wie wichtig es vielen tausenden
menschen in deutschland ist sich für
abrüstung und frieden auf die straße zu
begeben dafür zu demonstrieren und das
war ein gutes zeichen
frau b 1 war auch dass ihr anliegen ich
hoffe das vergessen sie nicht vielen
dank
frauen lastet hat sich hier die
wehrbeauftragte vorgenommen allerdings
muss man die berichte dann auch lesen
denn die wir überhaupt wer vögel hat im
zusammenhang mit afghanistan kein
untersuchungsausschuss gefordert sondern
eine enquetekommission das sind dann
doch schon feine unterschiede
nächste redner jetzt aus der spd falko
droßmann
er ist mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss und das ist heute
hier seine erste rede vor dem haus
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte wehrbeauftragte dr hügel liebe
kollegin auch im namen der spd
bundestagsfraktion den ganz herzlichen
dank für diesen 63 cents vorgelegt haben
meine damen und herren der uns
vorliegende 63 bericht der
wehrbeauftragten dieses hauses zeichnet
in guter tradition
ein objektives bild des zustandes
unserer streitkräfte und unserer
bundeswehrverwaltung ein bild das frei
ist von parteilichen tendenzen aber
parteiisch ist für unsere soldatinnen
soldaten und zivilbeschäftigten wie jede
und jeder vorherige inhaberin dieses
wichtigen amtes hat aber auch eva högl
ihre eigenen schwerpunkte gesetzt vor
allem begrüße ich die besondere
betrachtung der situation von frauen in
der bundeswehr sowie den neuen
schwerpunkt der umwelt und
klimapolitischen herausforderungen
unserer truppe ihnen
ihnen frau bundesministerin lamprecht
danke ich ausdrücklich für die schlüssel
die sie aus diesem bericht gezogen haben
und ich bin mir sicher dass sie diesen
bericht nicht nur als sachdarstellung
sondern als arbeitsauftrag verstehen
denn das ist der
denn das ist eher ein arbeitsauftrag und
so wurde in den letzten jahren auch
verstanden fühlt man sich die
plenardebatten der letzten jahre einmal
zu gemüte finden wir auch den immer
wiederkehrenden parlamentarischen ablauf
regierungsfraktionen loben das
ministerium opposition fordert endlich
konsequenzen aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der bericht des
wehrbeauftragten des deutschen
bundestages richtet sich nach meinem
verständnis doch gerade nicht an das
bundesverteidigungsministerium
sondern uns als parlament
es ist es ist doch unsere aufgabe und es
ist unsere werbeauftritte die uns um die
zustand die besonderen leistungen und
fehlentwicklungen unserer bundeswehr
unserer parlamentsarmee berichtet ich
möchte an dieser stelle mit ihrer
erlaubnis frau präsidentin aus dem
plenarsaal der 93 sitzung des deutschen
bundestages vom 28 juni 1955 zitieren
dort sagt der großartige sozialdemokrat
erich ollenhauer nämlich jede
militärische streitmacht ist nicht nur
ein teil der exekutive sondern sie
schafft aus ihrem wesen heraus ein stück
verfassungsrechtlicher wirklichkeit
neben der exekutive weil sie nach völlig
anderen grundsätzen aufgebaut ist als
die zivile verwaltung und weiter der
demokratische aufbau und die zivile
verwaltung sind daher nicht garantiert
in dem das militär die weisungsbefugnis
der weisungsbefugnis des
verteidigungsministers der
verteidigungsministerium unterstellt ist
und in dem es die verantwortlichkeit des
bundeskanzlers gegenüber dem parlament
gibt die position der streitkräfte sagt
ollenhauer muss durch direkte einwirkung
möglichkeiten des parlaments gesichert
sein
und meine damen und herren wenn wir den
betrieb parlaments am hier ernst nehmen
dann ist es doch unsere aufgabe die
notwendigen änderungen vorzunehmen wie
kommt es denn dass unsere streitkräfte
derzeit in einem zustand sind der ein
sondervermögen überhaupt nötig macht
liegt es nicht auch darin daran dass wir
es hier in diesem haus in den letzten
jahren versäumt haben den streitkräften
einen klaren auftrag zu geben und sie
entsprechend unseres auftrages auch
auszustatten wurde nicht stattdessen
ohne langfristige strategie eine
vielzahl von waffen system mit der folge
geschafft dass wir eine schier
unübersichtliche modellvielfalt haben
alles etwas können aber viel zu wenig
richtig liebe kolleginnen wie alle
beklagen eine überbordende bürokratie
oder sprechen gar von managementfehlern
in der sogenannten beschaffung aber sind
es nicht wir die regeln aufgestellt
haben das auch noch jede kultur jede
tube schuhcreme in einem langen
verfahren öffentlich ausgeschrieben
werden muss oder jede erprobung neuen
materials erst während der ausschreibung
des ausschreibungsverfahrens stattfinden
darf und dann beklagen wir uns über zu
lange bearbeitungszeiten der bundeswehr
sind es nicht wir die den bundesländern
und kommunen personal für bau und
sanierung militärischer einrichtungen
zur verfügung stellen nicht aber über
prüfen wofür dieses personal tatsächlich
eingesetzt wird sind es nicht wir die
über das stvg festgelegt haben dass auch
noch jeder panzer bei dem ein blinker
nicht richtig bringt vorübergehend
stillgelegt werden muss sind es nicht
wir die zu recht betroffen und
erschrocken die beispiele von
führungsversagen und verletzung der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
lesen und aufklärung und harte maßnahmen
fordern ohne dass wir uns fragen was die
ursachen sind wie kann es denn sein dass
eine wachsende anzahl von soldatinnen
und soldaten
in führungspositionen das bild des
staatsbürgers in uniform hinterfragen
und einen soldaten sui generis fordern
oder sich hohe und höchste stellte
offiziere nach beendigung ihres dienstes
und rechtsradikalen gruppen
zusammenschließen und mit hoher
pensionen jene freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekämpfen
die sie vorher tapfer also unter einsatz
ihres lebens verteidigen sollten einige
beispiele finden wir auch auf der
rechten seite des hauses hier
sie können dazwischen brüllen aber
ehrlicherweise ich bin seit mehr als 20
jahren ich bin seit mehr 20 jahren
offizier ich bin seit mehr als 20 jahren
offizier und meine haltung ist glasklar
der funktionär in der afc ist ist weder
als offizieren noch als unter offizieren
der bundeswehr tragbar
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nein ist
es die aufgabe dieses parlament ist sich
um eben diese fragen zu kümmern um die
attraktivität des dienstes um die frage
was in afghanistan falsch gelaufen ist
um die bezahlung der soldatinnen und
soldaten wobei wir uns natürlich darum
kümmern müssen dass die zulagen aus der
teams zeit der soldatinnen auf das
ruhegehalt angerechnet werden wie dies
für andere uniformträger des bundes
angekündigt wurde um die herausforderung
an militärische führung die ausstattung
die unsere aufträge erst ermöglicht und
die innere führung unser land und unsere
freiheit als mündige staatsbürger innen
zu verteidigen und verteidigen zu können
und zu wollen liebe kolleginnen auch das
ist zeitenwende werden wir unserer
verantwortung als parlament wieder
gerecht vielen dank
die erste rede von falko droßmann
bedacht mit viel applaus aus den eigenen
reihen auch die bündnisgrünen klatschen
beifall
die rednerin für die cdu csu fraktion
ist die kollegin sehr rasch kühler
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte frau
wehrbeauftragte zunächst möchte ich
ihnen vdr hügel ihnen und ihrem team
danken für ihren unermüdlichen einsatz
und ihre konstruktive arbeit gänzlich in
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
in ihrem jahresbericht
2021 bekommen wir aufschluss über den
zustand der bundeswehr sowie auch über
die stimmung und auch über die
missstände in der truppe aber auch in
anderer hinsicht ist der bericht sehr
aufschlussreich bereits zu beginn ihres
berichtes gehen sie auf die rede des
bundeskanzlers am 27 februar an dieser
stelle ein und auch sie haben ganz
offensichtlich den bundeskanzler genau
so verstanden wie der rest der
bevölkerung
deutschland wird ab sofort mehr als zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandproduktes in den
verteidigungshaushalt investieren und
zusätzlich
zusätzlich ein sondervermögen
bundeswehr in höhe von 100 milliarden
euro aufsetzen nachzulesen in dem
bericht der wehrbeauftragte ich lieber
herr kollege aber okay das soll anders
gemeint gewesen sein das muss vorher das
muss ich das muss der rest der
bevölkerung hierzu kenntnis nehmen und
dennoch dennoch möchte ich hier
klarstellen dass wir ausdrücklich ihre
aufforderung brauchen geld an dieses
hochhaus ihre aufforderung unterstützen
im verteidigungshaushalt deutlich zu
erhöhen wir müssen dauerhaft mehr als 20
in die bundeswehr investieren das
erwarten unsere partner und verbündeten
aber genau das erfordert auch die
aktuelle bedrohungslage
nur dann wird die auch so groß
angekündigte zeitenwende wirklich mit
leben gefüllt werden denn ihr bericht
zeigt das geld wird dringend gebraucht
gerade für die persönliche ausstattung
und ausrüstung unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten und davon konnte ich mich auch
letztens rahmen eines besuchs bei
unserer battle group in litauen
überzeugen das muss man an dieser stelle
leider auch ganz offen und ehrlich sagen
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten vor ort
sind diejenigen ihr haben schlechtesten
ausgestattet sind und das obwohl wir
dort führungs nationen sind das feld an
bei der bekleidung geht rüber zu
funkgeräten sowie aber auch dass unsere
soldaten nach wie vor die einzigen sind
die im gepanzerten fahrzeugen mit karten
arbeiten müssen während andere schon
digital unterwegs sind und wer dafür
verantwortlich ist lieber herr kollege
das haben wir glaube ich in den letzten
tagen hier sehr sehr erörtern und klar
ist geworden dass sich hier keiner von
dieser verantwortung freisprechen kann
gerade nicht ihre fraktionen dabei
es ist auch ihre größte zeit vor möbel
gerade auch schon deutlich gemacht es
ist ausdrücklich zu begrüßen es sehr in
guter zusammenarbeit zwischen der
bundesregierung und dem bundestag die
2,4 milliarden euro für die
schutzausrüstung und für die bekleidung
jetzt schnell und flexibel
bereitgestellt werden dies wird die
motivation der männer und frauen noch
mal steigern und es ist ein zeichen des
respekts liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
darüber hinaus müssen wir aber auch
weitere bedürfnisse der soldatinnen und
soldaten im auge behalten und auch hier
insbesondere der frauen diese
bedürfnisse müssen stärker in den fokus
gerückt werden denn sie stellen zu recht
fest frau vögel dass die strukturen der
bundeswehr auf männliche soldaten
ausgerichtet sind es dienen immer noch
knapp 13 prozent nur knapp 13 prozent
frauen in der bundeswehr also müssen wir
uns auch hier hier gemeinsam als
abgeordnete gedanken machen wie wir den
dienst in der bundeswehr für frauen
attraktiver machen können zum beispiel
müssen dienst und familienpflichten
kombinierbarer werden die vereinbarkeit
von beruf und familie ist ein großes
thema in der aktiven truppe aber aber
auch bei den reservistinnen und
reservisten
sie müssen viele verpflichtungen
miteinander koordinieren zwischen ihren
beruf ihrer familie und dem reservisten
dienst auch ihnen danke ich ausdrücklich
für ihr engagement
grade in der fluthilfe oder auch in der
pandemie diese rolle für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
wird in diesen zeiten wieder zentral für
die verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres
landes im verteidigungsfall müsste eine
große zahl reservisten herangezogen
werden wir sehen hier von mehreren
zehntausend doch die software dafür die
diese mammutaufgabe stemmen soll stammt
aus den zeiten des kalten krieges die
digitalisierung und personalwesen muss
also schneller und flexibler gestaltet
werden und kann sich nicht an die
normalen beschaffungswege halten die
mittlerweile mehrere jahre dauern könnte
bis dahin ist eine implementierung bzw
die it der implementierung schon längst
überholt und das ist nur eine der
widrigkeiten er unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten teilweise ausgesetzt sind wie
wir in dem bericht nachlesen können und
umso bemerkenswerter ist es wie
selbstverständlich und höchst motiviert
sie immer wieder außerordentliches
leisten und dafür gilt ihnen unser aller
dank liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
strengen wir uns gemeinsam an ziehen wir
gemeinsam lehren aus diesem bericht und
sorgen dafür dass motivation und freude
am dienst für unser land stärker
gewürdigt werden indem wir die belange
der tour auch künftig stärker
respektiert herzlichen dank
der bundestag debattiert über den
jahresbericht 20 21 der
wehrbeauftragten und die in nächste
rednerin kommt von den bündnisgrünen
sara nanni sie ist die
sicherheitspolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion
zunächst möchte ich der wehrbeauftragten
und dem ganzen team für ihre arbeit
danken der bericht und der
kontinuierliche dieses kontinuierliche
am puls der truppe seien sind eine sehr
wichtige unterstützung unserer
parlamentarischen arbeit
der bericht zeigt die werbe das von der
truppe im letzten jahr war enorm im
rahmen der amtshilfe haben soldatinnen
fiel auch das getan was eben nicht zu
ihrem kernauftrag der
leistungsverteilung gehört im zentrum im
gesundheitsamt im alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen haben sie im rahmen
der pandemie überall dort hand angelegt
wo es nötig war und ich sage ihnen auch
ganz ehrlich manche kommunen sind mit
der bereitschaft zur amtshilfe
verantwortungsvoller umgang als andere
und auch in der flutkatastrophe im juli
120 mit ihren verheerenden folgen für so
viele menschen waren soldaten im einsatz
die bauten druck und halfen bäume und
trümmer aus flussbetten und von straßen
zu räumen die soldaten haben wir enormes
geleistet sie haben den dank der
bevölkerung direkt gespürt und ich denke
ich spreche für das ganze haus will auch
ich hier danke danke
frage reicht aber nicht das zeigt der
bericht liebe frau wehrbeauftragte und
ich habe es auch selbst erfahren als ich
ende dezember letzten jahres in rogla
die truppe bei der in hellste pressung
drittel gut besucht habe dort habe ich
mit soldaten gesprochen und sie
erzählten von ihrer arbeit die schon
damals in einem sicherheitspolitisch
sehr angespannten umfeld stattfand und
auch über ihre persönliche ausstattung
im einsatz haben sie gesprochen und auch
darüber dass die ausstattung nicht immer
angemessen ist sie beschaffen sich in
der konsequenz dass eine oder andere
teilen auf mich alles ganz billig selber
und die bundeswehr ist eine
parlamentsarmee und auch wenn wir
einsätze wie in rogla nicht mandatieren
wir sind doch verantwortlich wenn die
truppe unzureichend ausgestattet ist
wenn er soll der ordentlich aber nicht
üppig ist teilweise dafür draufgeht dass
man erst mal die persönliche ausstattung
so vervollständigen muss dass man sein
auftrag optimal erfüllen kann das muss
doch anders gehen
und ich will liebe frau ministerin auch
optimistisch dass es anders gehen wird
ich bin der ministerin auf dem
generalinspekteur sehr dankbar auch dem
haushaltsausschuss natürlich dass sie
als eine der ersten entscheidung in
dieser wahlperiode ganz klar gemacht
haben es wird kein land und keine
soldaten werfen die persönliche
ausstattung bangen
das ist nicht nur ein wichtiges signal
dass etwas mit respekt zu tun und
respekt heißt so viel mehr
und da bleiben wir weiter in der pflicht
ihr bericht 176 seiten sind das sind
hausaufgaben für das bmvg aber auch für
dieses haus
respekt heißt aber auch dass frauen in
der bundeswehr selbstverständlich sind
und sexismus geächtet wird dass menschen
unabhängig von religion sexueller
orientierung und geschlechtliche
identität
hautfarbe oder biografie alle gleich
behandelt
und es heißt auch dass kameradschaft
nicht denjenigen
das dass die kameradschaft und das heißt
auch dass die kameradschaft nicht
derjenige gefährdet der rechtes
gedankengut
anprangert sondern derjenige der es in
die gruppe trägt
respekt heißt auch dass wir im parlament
sehr genau prüfen in welche einsätze wie
unsere soldatinnen mit welchem auftrag
zum senden und dass wir diejenigen die
mit seelische und körperliche runden
zurück kommen gut versorgen das ist
indes insbesondere mit blick auf das
ende des afghanistan einsatzes wurde
hier mehrfach angesprochen ein großes
thema dem wir uns noch mehr widmen
möchten die bewerbe auftrag
2606 persönliche eingabe
3967 vorgänger insgesamt haben sie und
ihr team im letzten jahr ausgewertet in
zahlreichen besuchen bei der truppe
haben sie zugehört und haben sich
ansprechbar gezeigt danke dass sie ihre
arbeit so gewissenhaft machen damit wir
unsere arbeit gewissenhafter machen
können
jetzt würde ich noch ein paar dinge
klarstellen frontlastig ich finde es
unangemessen dass ihr der
wehrbeauftragten hier unterstellt den
auftrag nicht gerecht zu werden der
bericht zeigt das gegenteil
ihre unterstellung ist und fragen und an
die union nur eine frage sie haben ja
wichtige herausforderung angesprochen wo
wann denn die parlamentarier der union
die letzten 16 jahren
trinkt komme ich noch die afg ruf da
rein der erste mann der gedient hat
sie haben genau die dem bundestag
gerettet weil er in der truppe keine
perspektiven er hatte das ist doch die
wahrheit und wissen sie was für
kameraden die sie stellt man sich in der
bundeswehr
neben der fdp sie niemand der dieses
land und diese werte die dem dieses land
und diese werte am herzen liegen bietet
sich einem autokraten club touting so an
wie sie das regelmäßig in diesem haus
tun
sara nanni was für die bündnisgrünen
der bundestag debattiert hier über den
jahresbericht der beauftragten sie hat
heute morgen den bericht aus der wahl
vorgestellt auch den
verteidigungsministern hat bereits
gesprochen und gelobt dass der bundestag
2,4 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt die persönliche
ausrüstung her genau um den es hier
schon häufiger gegen hat es noch eines
fordern weil sie mich persönlich
angesprochen haben nicht die afg hat
mich in den bundestag gehievt oder
gerettet in meinem wahlkreis habe ich
das zweitstärkste ergebnis geholt mit
über 20 prozent der direkt mandat
stimmen ihr kandidat herr keller landete
bei 3 prozent die bürger ist deutschen
volkes haben mich hier rein gewählt und
nicht die fdp hinein gehievt oder
gerettet das muss man klar gestellt
werden vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich rufe auf den nächsten redner für die
fdp-fraktion alexander müller
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen frau hügel ich darf ihnen
zuerst für ihren engagierten einsatz für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten danken
mit ihrem bericht legen sie wieder die
stellen offen an denen die politik im
obligo ist die probleme der truppe
abzustellen es ist ein ganz wichtiges
papier eine art checkliste würde ich als
berufs pilot sagen die wir in diesem
haus abzuarbeiten haben ihr bericht 20
21 geht ausführlich auf das ende des
afghanistan einsatzes eine zäsur in der
geschichte der bundeswehr afghanistan
war der intensivste und der
verlustreichste auslandseinsatz der
bundeswehr der bericht ist erneuter
anlass zum gedenken an die 59
soldatinnen und soldaten die aus diesem
einsatz nicht wieder lebendig nach hause
gekommen sind und auch an die vielen
körperlich und seelisch verwundeten für
deren fürsorge wir hier als parlament in
der schuld stehen wir danken heute allen
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten die
weltweit für uns den kopf hinhalten um
unsere aufträge zu erfüllen und frieden
in der welt abzusichern
jetzt kommen wir mal kurz zu den zahlen
der kollege von der afg sprach eben von
seinen millionen wählern beim
bundeswahlleiter kann man es ja sehr
genau nachvollziehen es waren 26.000
sind also ein paar nullen wild
durcheinander geraten aber auch über die
cdu muss man sich doch heute wundern
weil beide rednerinnen und das ist ja
schon fast vergnügungssteuerpflichtig
ist ein finanzministerium keiner da der
mir im hut rumgehen könnte aber das war
schon unterhaltsam also die union hatte
in der mittelfristigen finanzplanung der
letzten bundesregierung waren für dieses
jahr 46 milliarden und ein paar
zerquetschte vorgesehen gewesen wir als
ampel haben 50 milliarden auf den tisch
gelegt und dann kritisieren sie und die
aracom und dann kommt das sondervermögen
und da stehen sie ja auch nicht da
wissen sie auch nicht was sie wollen
also der fraktionsvorsitzende mehrzahl
angekündigt 75 stimmen will er uns
gönnen für die grundgesetzänderung mit
den 100 milliarden und der rest stimmt
dann irgendwie anders als das heißt sie
sind entweder in der union tief
gespalten oder sie wollen hier taktische
spielchen spielen und das ist
unangemessen für die wenn es um das wohl
und soldatinnen und soldaten geht das
ist kein staatspolitisches handlung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gestern
haben hier mehrere redner verlangt dass
wir die ukraine nicht weiter bei der
selbstverteidigung unterstützen sollten
dass wir putin nicht weiter stören
sollten wenn er die bevölkerung dort
auslöscht die stammtisch formel wer
waffen liefert befeuert immer den krieg
die stimmt nicht viele von uns die
geglaubt haben man könnte ohne waffen
oder abschreckung dauerhaften frieden
haben sind in diesem jahr in der
realität aufgewacht wladimir putin
beeindruckend keine gespräche ihn
interessiert doch das völkerrecht nicht
und geschlossene verträge interessieren
hier auch nicht seine gegner bringt da
einfach um wir sind hier in deutschland
zeuge dabei ein aggressor stoppen wir
nicht mit einem sitzkreis und ausgiebige
diskussionen das haben fast alle
mittlerweile verstanden einen aggressor
beeindruckt nur wirksame abschreckung
oder ich zitiere ein gutes zitat meiner
kollegen strack-zimmermann verhandlungen
aber mit sichtbarer hand am puls unserer
abschreckung ist eine starke bundeswehr
in der ukraine verteidigt sich gerade
die freie welt gegen den neoliberalismus
erst wenn freiheit das recht auf leben
auf körperliche unversehrtheit
fähre gerichtsurteile meinungsfreiheit
wenn das plötzlich nicht mehr vorhanden
ist dann erkennen wir deren wert die
bundeswehr ist unser garant für genau
diese freiheitlichen werte und ich bin
froh und dankbar dass die bundeswehr
jetzt auch verstärkt neue bewerberinnen
und bewerber bekommt weil sie den sinn
stiften kann denn viele junge menschen
aus ihrem künftigen beruf ziehen wollen
jede unserer soldatinnen jeder soldat
riskiert seine körperliche
unversehrtheit und dient dafür diese
unsere art zu leben zu verteidigen
ich bin allen dafür sehr dankbar und
deswegen sollten wir noch wesentlich
mehr leisten für den respekt in die
truppe sich verdient und zu diesem
respekt gehört eine anständige
ausrüstung oder materielle ausstattung
die diese regierungskoalition jetzt
nachhaltig und glaubwürdig bereitstellt
vielen dank
die nächste redner kommt von der cdu das
ist florian hahn erst der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und er kommt
natürlich von der csu
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kollegen und kollegen jetzt hat der
kollege christian petry leider den saal
verlassen aber ich möchte mal sagen also
ich hab das er als einen
kameradschaftlichen hinweis von kollegen
petri verstanden an den kollegen knapp
aber
das sei nur
noch vorweg gestellt
sehr geehrte frau werbeauftrag der
vielen herzlichen dank für ihren 63
bericht nicht ihren sondern den 63
bericht des wehrbeauftragten des films
organ des deutschen bundestages und
vielen dank dass sie einmal mehr den
finger in die wunde gelegt haben und
wieder sozusagen eine mängelliste in
form dieses berichtes vorgelegt haben
was diesen zustand unser der ausrüstung
ausstattung et cetera aber auch die
sonstigen angelegenheiten unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten angeht und auch
wenn sie nicht zuständig sind für die
gesamte bundeswehr sondern nur für die
184000 soldatinnen soldaten möchte ich
einfach weil sonst auch das ein bisschen
oft untergeht möchte ich auch sagen dass
nicht nur die 184000 soldatinnen
soldaten eine tolle arbeit und leistung
ablegen sondern auch alle zivilen
mitarbeiter die für und beide bundes
bearbeiten und das möchte ich an dieser
stelle auch als sagen
wow wehrbeauftragte sie haben in ihrer
rede viele wichtige punkte angesprochen
sie haben beispielsweise auch wieder auf
die amtshilfe
rekrutiert und da möchte ich sagen ja es
ist gut dass die amtshilfe jetzt beendet
wurde oder in weiten teilen beendet
wurde aber ich will sagen wir sollten
nicht nur feststellen dass es richtig
ist dass sie beendet wurde sondern wir
müssen mit blick darauf was in diesen
zwei jahren amtshilfe allein für das
thema krone was an ausbildung nicht
geleistet werden konnte was an problemen
dadurch bei der bundeswehr tatsächliche
auftritt sollten wir jetzt auch den
hinweis los werden und zwar an bund
länder und an die entsprechenden
institutionen die eigentlich für diese
aufgabenerfüllung zuständig gewesen
wären jetzt die lehre daraus zu ziehen
und diese strukturen für die zukunft
aufzubauen denn wir werden das
tatsächlich nicht noch mal in diesem
ausmaß leisten können und das müssen wir
denjenigen die dafür verantwortlich sind
auf einen ebenen auch ins stammbuch
schreiben frau wehrbeauftragten sie
haben beim thema ausrüstung ausstattung
auch wieder einmal auch hier den finger
in die wunde gelegt und es ist richtig
dass wir hier viele defizite haben und
darüber diskutieren wir ja schon jetzt
munter seit vielen vielen wochen und das
wird auch sicherlich noch ein paar
wochen so weitergehen wichtig ist dass
wir tatsächlich natürlich zu einem punkt
kommen und tatsächlich verbesserung
erreichen ich komme da noch das aber ein
wichtiger punkt dabei ist natürlich das
thema beschaffung und organisation von
beschaffung und wir brauchen hier
weniger bürokratie wir brauchen ein
schnelleres vorgehen schnellere
entscheidungen etc und deswegen war ich
sehr sehr
positiv gestimmt als bei den ersten
äußerungen am abend die bundesministerin
angekündigt hat hier beim beim thema
beschaffung dann schwerpunkt ihrer
arbeit draufzusetzen und dann wurde kurz
danach berichtet freudestrahlend dass
man jetzt also schon mal die bei der
anhebung der unterschwelligen
beschaffung jetzt von 1000 auf 5000 euro
geht und dann wurde noch berichtet dass
man jetzt in zukunft noch mehr oder
öfters die möglichkeit nach europäischen
recht nutzen möchte auch ohne
ausschreibung zu beschaffen
hund aber das war es bisher ich will nur
sagen das ist nicht der durchbruch wenn
wir darüber reden die wir tatsächlich
beschaffung tatsächlich besser
organisieren wollen und der truppe dass
er schneller und effektiver das an die
hand geben wollen was sie tatsächlich
braucht hier braucht es mehr alarm frau
bundesministerin das erwarte ich und
wenn ich sie sagen dass dem dass das
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden ein
booster ist dann bin ich nur sagen
passen sie auf dass dieser booster nicht
zum rohrkrepierer wird und wir stehen
dem sondervermögen deswegen so wie sie
es jetzt wollen so kritisch gegenüber
weil sie nämlich erst bei scholz erst
angekündigt habe er möchte gerne 100
milliarden plus dass zwei prozent ziel
und daraus wurde jetzt 2 prozent - 100
milliarden und das werden wir so nicht
mittragen können denn wir werden dann 1
erleben dass wenn wir der meinung sind
heute dass in der vergangenheit die
bundeswehr unterfinanziert war
strukturell unterfinanziert dann werden
wir das wenn dieser strohfeuer 100
milliarden verbraucht es genau dort
wieder landen wenn wir bis dahin die
finanz linien nicht auch die zwei
prozent nato ziel gebracht haben und das
wissen sie und deswegen werden sie sich
auch diesen vorwurf gefallen lassen
müssen machen sie aus diesen aus diesem
sondervermögen nicht an wirklich einen
booster und nicht ein strohfeuer und
geben sie der bundeswehr was sie braucht
nämlich zwei prozent nachdruck viel und
zwar für nicht nur jetzt und dieses jahr
sondern für die nächste dekade
herzlichen dank
florian hahn hier nochmal mit der
forderung der cdu csu
des 2 prozent ziels für die ausstattung
der bundeswehr
bild für bild jetzt für die spd fraktion
frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau wehrbeauftragte dr hügel
dem dank an sie und ihr gesamtes team
kann ich mich uneingeschränkt
anschließen für alle die sich einen
überblick über die aktuellen themen in
der bundeswehr verschaffen möchten ist
der bericht erwerbe auftraten eine
unverzichtbare lektüre
verständlich und mit vielen
anschaulichen beispielen muss man kein
fachpolitiker sein um in die großen und
kleinen probleme unserer parlamentsarmee
einzutauchen das amt der
wehrbeauftragten in deutschland ist
weltweit einzigartig und auf das
besondere verhältnis von bundestag und
bundeswehr zurückzuführen und es ist der
bundestag der über die einsätze unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten entscheidet der
sie ausstattet und ausrüstet und der
eine besondere verantwortung für alle
angehörigen unserer streitkräfte trägt
der jahresbericht zeigt eindrucksvoll
auf was unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
im letzten jahr geleistet haben
von der amtshilfe im kampf gegen korona
und der bewältigung der
hochwasserkatastrophe über die einsätze
im rahmen unserer unseres
internationalen engagement bis hin zur
evakuierungs mission in afghanistan
zum teil ohne große vorlaufzeiten und
mit hoher einsatzbereitschaft waren
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten auch im
vergangenen jahr stets zur stelle und
fakten dort mit an wo sie gebraucht
wurden
dass die bundeswehr amtshilfe leisten
kann ist spätestens seit der geleisteten
unterstützung im gesundheitsbereich
allen bekannt hier waren bis zu 19.000
soldatinnen und soldaten gleichzeitig im
einsatz amtshilfe darf aber nicht zur
daueraufgabe werden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der kernauftrag der
bundeswehr ist die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
und um diesen auftrag erfüllen zu können
braucht sie gutes personal und material
das bundesministerium der verteidigung
strebte zuletzt in seiner
mittelfristigen personalplanung bis 2027
eine personalstärke von rund 2.200 3000
soldatinnen und soldaten an mit stand
vom 28
februar 22
leisteten fast 184 1000 frauen und
männer ihren dienst bei der bundeswehr
das ist eine differenz von fast 19.000
da haben wir also noch große aufgaben
vor uns positiv festzuhalten ist
zunächst dass es der bundeswehr gelungen
ist trotz pandemie bedingte
einschränkung ein personalbestand von
99,8 prozent des vorjahres niveau zu
halten und die neubewerber zahlen im
vergleich zum vorjahr weiter zu steigern
auch die zahl der soldatinnen und
soldaten auf zeit mit einer langen
verpflichtungszeit von 15 jahren oder
mehr ist in den letzten jahren stark
angestiegen um die personal lücke zu
schließen muss die attraktivität der
bundeswehr als arbeitgeberin weiter
gesteigert werden um das zu erreichen
sind weiterhin erhebliche anstrengungen
nötig die im jahresbericht geschilderten
probleme bei der vereinbarkeit von
dienst und familie
notwendige verbesserungen der
rahmenbedingungen beim laufbahn wechsel
und die reduzierung unbesetzter
dienstposten will ich hier nur
exemplarisch nennen wenn die bundeswehr
neues personal finden und dauerhaft
halten möchte spielt gute ausstattung
eine elementare rolle
über die defizite bei der
einsatzbereitschaft von großgeräten
haben wir in letzter zeit bereits
ausführlich diskutiert vom anspruch
train suv ist die bundeswehr immer noch
viel zu weit entfernt
bei der persönlichen bekleidung und
ausrüstung gab es positive entwicklung
vielen dank frau ministerin lambrecht
dass sie gerade in diesem bereich einen
ersten schwerpunkt gesetzt haben mehr
und schneller schon 2025 wird die aktive
truppe mit der lange geforderten
persönliche schutzausstattung
ausgestattet sein sechs jahre früher als
ursprünglich geplant
so kann man muss es weitergehen
die zahlreichen berichte über den
schlechten zustand von unterkünften
sanitäreinrichtungen sportstätten und
anderen gebäuden sind jedoch beschämt
selbst wenn die finanziellen mittel
vorhanden sind so scheitert es bisher
und das teilweise seit jahren an der
umsetzung vieler bauvorhaben es ist
höchste zeit die probleme mit den
bauverwaltungen der bundesländer zu
lösen die werbeauftrag hat hierzu einen
appell an die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder gerichtet
den ich noch mal deutlich unterstreichen
möchte liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der werbe richtzeit durch nicht auch
wenn es im letzten jahr viele positive
entwicklungen gegeben hat bis zu einer
vollumfänglichen ausstattung unserer
bundeswehr in allen bereichen haben wir
noch einen beiden weg nun gilt es das
geplante sondervermögen schnellstmöglich
und effektiv auf den weg zu bringen
vielen dank
apple hat hier als letzter redner in
ganz wichtigen punkt in seiner rede
angesprochen nämlich die bundeswehr als
arbeitgeber attraktiv zu machen die
rekrutierung neuer
kräfte dass es diese diskussion
eigentlich etwas zu kurz gekommen
das war also die debatte über den
jahresbericht 20 21 und in der tat wenn
man hört dass die persönliche ausrüstung
bis zum jahr 2025 jetzt bereitgestellt
werden soll damit einem angst und bange
wenn man an die aktuellen ereignisse
denkt die gerade in der keine
stattfinden und die durchaus ja nicht so
weit entfernt sind von unserem
bundesgebiet und wenn man dann noch hört
dass 2025 sechs jahre schneller dann die
ausrüstung bereit hin als sie
ursprünglich geplant war dann weiß man
wo unter anderem die probleme bei der
bundeswehr und verein die
bundeswehrverwaltung hängen und insofern
ist die vorgesehene 100 milliarden
spritze zwar sehr großzügig aber
offensichtlich notwendig um hier die
defizite auch gerade in der
waffentechnik schnell
so jetzt darf ich ihnen noch ganz kurz
sagen weil es um den abgang es genau die
ganze zeit ja alles genau ist vom immer
die tatsächlich als rechtsextremist
eingeschätzt worden er hat offen gegen
asylbewerber und ausländer hetzt er war
personal feldwebel durch die dritte
monate seiner dienstzeit nicht mehr auf
seinem posten verbringen und wurde dann
in den deutschen bundestag gewählt und
als einer von vier april für die afc in
den verteidigungsausschuss was bei den
anderen fraktionen zu keinerlei
begeisterung führte dass der hintergrund
zu der doch häufen auseinandersetzung
mit dem redner hannes genau im
verteidigungsausschuss sitzt er für die
afc jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
nächsten programmpunkt top 23 impulse
für einzelhandel und innenstädte ein
antrag der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
nachhaltigen kurse für einzelne und
innenstädte so heißt der anzahl und
darin fordert die unions fraktion die
bundesregierung auf den einzelhandel und
die attraktivität der innenstädte mit
insgesamt 20 maßnahmen zu unterstützen
und
und carsten lüdemann hat als erster
redner hier das wort
erster stellvertreter franz vorsitzender
und stellvertreter im parteivorsitz
und kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ich möchte mit einem zitat
einsteigen
auf architekturzeichnungen ist es immer
still in städten
das hat mal vor einiger zeit der
niederländische schriftsteller cees
nooteboom gesagt heute würde ihm denke
ich mal dieses zitat nicht mehr so
leicht über die lippen gehen auf
architektur zeichnung ist es immer still
im städten
fakt ist die innenstädte in deutschland
werden immer stiller wir haben viel
leerstand im ruhrgebiet gibt städte wo
jedes dritte ladenlokal
ruhig gestellt ist ein euro läden aber
auch ein euro shops aber auch handy
läden und vieles mehr prägen das
innenstadt leben zu sehen
ich komme selbst aus einem
einzelhandelsgeschäft meine eltern
hatten über 40 jahre eine buchhandlung
ich war damals laut junge wie das so war
musste die botengänge erledigen in den
90er jahren die stadt war vielfältig die
stadt war kleinteilig es gab
qualifizierten
einzelhandel es gab eigentümergeführte
unternehmen hier statt jede innenstadt
sei irgendwie anders aus
das hat sich heute geändert heute sieht
eben wie jede innenstadt gleich aus wir
verlieren jedes jahr tausende geschäfte
in diesem jahr die prognose
16.000 schließung in den deutschen
innenstädten vor allem der kleine
fachhandel ja wir erleben einen
strukturwandel die digitalisierung hat
den einzelhandel verändert und die
corona klinik krise diese entwicklung
nochmals
beschleunigt man muss sich das auf der
zunge zergehen lassen im ersten corona
jahr 2020 ist der onlinehandel um 20 25
prozent gestiegen auf 70 milliarden
jahresumsatz und ein jahr später
nochmals um 20 prozent auf 100
milliarden nicht dass sie mich falsch
verstehen die cdu csu fraktion bildet
diesen strukturwandel nicht aufhalten
ganz im gegenteil diejenigen
mittelständler in den innenstädten die
stationär sehr erfolgreich sind sind
auch in der regel online technisch sehr
erfolgreich nein uns geht es um einen
anderen punkt wir wollen mit diesem
antrag dagegen halten gegen die verödung
der innenstädte wir wollen die zukunft
der innenstädte wir werden wir wollen
die innenstädte als erlebnisraum
schaffen als begegnungsstätte als
kommunikationsplattform wo sich menschen
treffen wo sich menschen austauschen das
ist der kitt der unsere gesellschaft
zusammenhält
dieser antrag hat sehr viele punkte ich
schaffe das aus zeitgründen nicht auf
alle punkte einzugehen aber ich hab mir
mal erlaubt persönlich so die drei
punkte heraus zu ziehen die meines
erachtens im moment zentral sind der
erste punkt ist der kurzfristige im
stationären handel ist es so in
deutschland dass die frequenz immer noch
20 25 prozent in den innenstädten
unterhalb des krisen niveaus liegt jetzt
kommt die ukraine krise eine große
verunsicherung der einzelhandel spricht
davon dass wir eine umsatz konnte im
moment haben und deshalb sind wir der
meinung das beste instrument das beste
steuerliche kurzfristige instrument um
diesen einzelhandel zu helfen ist die
verlustverrechnung dass wir
gewinnen
der vergangenheit mit den verlusten von
heute verrechnen weil wir dann zielgenau
und die unternehmen treffen die die
zukunft auf ihrer seite haben ja die in
digitalisierung investieren wollen nun
vieles mehr der zweite punkt städtebau
und stadtplanung der kollege ulrich
lange wird gleich auf dieses thema
eingehen aber lassen sie mich einsatz
dazu sagen die städte der zukunft werden
sich verändern wir werden mehr wohnraum
schaffen müssen in den innenstädten
übrigens auch mehr leben wir brauchen
auch mehr junge menschen wir sehen ja in
den städten wo junge menschen sind wo
universitäten teile ihrer universität in
die innenstädte legen wie beispielsweise
münster die freiburg wie bayreuth da ist
leben mindert aber auch das thema
sicherheit es kann nicht sein ich
spreche mal von meiner person ich habe
zwei drei jahren mal in frankfurt gelebt
ich habe wirklich auf der zeil meine
wohnung gehabt da war abends nichts mehr
los weil die leute nicht in die stadt
gegangen sind weil sie angst hatten weil
der no go areas waren genau dagegen
müssen wir halten übrigens wird das gut
macht ist der nordrhein-westfälische
innenminister er betreut wirklich
dagegen vor auch das ist innenstadt
politik für die zukunft der dritte punkt
bin der meinung der einst lange brauchen
mehr aufmerksamkeit
ich beobachte mich selbst dabei ich
werde angesprochen damit gesagt herr
lindemann müssen wir über die
öffnungszeiten reden dann sage ich nee
das ist landespolitik dann geht es über
die erreichbarkeit dass kommunalpolitik
die landespolitiker sagen denn zum
städtebau geben das ist bundespolitik
damit muss schluss sein wir müssen eine
plattform schaffen wo sich alle begegnen
alle an eine allianz für den innenstadt
für die innenstädte das land bund und
kommunen gemeinsam ganzheitlich dieses
thema betrachtet und nicht jeder immer
wie bei anderen themen auch die
verantwortung wegschiebt und nicht
selber die verantwortung tragen will
dafür steht die cdu/csu und es
lassen sich zum schluss noch eine
persönliche anmerkung machen ich bin
hier spontan eingesprungen ich will mich
auch nicht mit fremden federn schmücken
dieser antrag ist maßgeblich verfasst
wurden von metzler jan metzler ab corona
wünschen ihnen alles gute genesung
herzliche grüße auch hier aus dem
deutschen bundestag in berlin
ich habe mich heute gerne vertreten weil
dieses thema auch für mich ein
herzensanliegen ist ich hab' skizziert
warum das der fall ist nicht nur für
mich als person sondern auch für die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und ich würde
sie bitten diesen antrag nicht einfach
aus parteitaktischen gründen weg zu
schmettern sondern sich ernsthaft mit
diesem antrag in unseren argumenten
auseinanderzusetzen herzlichen
carsten linnemann in der tat
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende der
cdu ist er seit dezember aber seit
dezember ist er nicht mehr
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
so viel muss noch mal gesagt werden er
war ja lange jahre der vorsitzende der
mittelstandsvereinigung insofern war er
hier heute auch der richtige ersatz
redner für die cdu/csu der
mittelstandsbeauftragte der spd
esra limbacher hat jetzt das wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
koalition ist eine die handelt und nicht
einfach nur redet oder papiere erstellt
diese koalition ist eine die felsenfest
hinter einem stabilen und
zukunftssicheren einzelhandel in unserem
land steht ein einzelhandel der nicht
nur eine wohnortnahe versorgung
gewährleistet sondern der einer der
wichtigsten faktoren für lebendige
innenstädte und ortszentren in unseren
gemeinden ist und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union ist grenzt schon
ein wenig so ein bisschen an
dreistigkeit hier in diesem hause heute
wohlfeile forderungen zur zukunft
unserer innenstädte zu erheben während
das zuständige innenministerium
16 jahre unionsgeführten und diese
probleme verschlafen blockiert und
ignoriert hat diese probleme von heute
sind versäumnisse von gestern liebe
kolleginnen und wegen
deswegen lässt sich der antrag auch wie
ein schulbuch über das was sie in den
vergangenen jahren eben nicht geschafft
haben insofern sage ich danke schön für
diese auflistung sage ihnen aber auch
wir werden es besser machen
diese auflistung wäre allerdings
tatsächlich gar nicht nötig gewesen denn
das allermeiste findet sich schon längst
in unserem wahlprogramm in unserem
koalitionsvertrag oder in der innenstadt
strategie von der cia maßgeblich
abgeschrieben haben in diesem antrag
copy & paste das kann jeder wir bekennen
uns zur innenstadt strategie und führen
die sofort genauso wie das
förderprogramm zukunftsfähige
innenstädte und zentren und genauso wie
das programm lebendige zentren im rahmen
des bund länder
städtebauförderung die zeiten und da
haben sie recht sind aber viel zu ernst
für einfache parteipolitik denn der
einzelhandel steckt tatsächlich seit
jahren in einer ernsten krise
vordergründig das stimmt sind die zahlen
tatsächlich gut wir sehen positive
umsatzentwicklung aber wenn man mal
rechts und links neben den
lebensmitteleinzelhandel schaut sehen
wir dass dem stationären vor allen
dingen non food handel bei der
bekleidung zum beispiel minus 32 prozent
umsatzrückgang im vergleich zu 2009 10
bei dem bei den schulen verkäufen minus
35 prozent umsatzrückgang bei den
spielwaren und sportartikel minus 15
prozent umsatzrückgang das alles sind
keine guten zahlen und diese entwicklung
des einzelhandel ist doch eng verknüpft
wie mit den innenstädten und dorfzentren
und ortszentren in unseren gemeinden
denn dass die innenstädte veröden ist
nicht erst seit der korona krise ein
problem sondern wird doch spätestens
seit dem aufkommen des onlinehandels und
dem trend einkaufszentren auf der so
genannten grünen wiese zu bauen
beklagt in unserem land aber warum sind
uns die innenstädte und ortszentren in
unserem land so wichtig und warum ist
der einzelhandel uns eingesetzt der
beziehung so wichtig innenstädte und
zentren in unseren gemeinden sind echte
identifikation sword für die gesamte
bürgerschaft sie sind neben ihrer
wirtschaftlichen bedeutung vor allen
dingen doch soziale politische und
kulturelle
zentren unseres gemeinwesens sie sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
visitenkarten unserer städte und
gemeinden und deswegen lohnt sich jede
investition jede bemühung um sie zu
fördern und deswegen ist es richtig dass
diese koalition auf eine revitalisierung
der innenstädte und ortszentren
ernsthaft setzt und beim städtebau beim
wohnungsbau nicht halt macht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie mich das gemüse aber noch
einen wie ich finde ganz wichtigen punkt
machen der stationäre handel in
deutschland braucht attraktive
rahmenbedingungen und im strukturwandel
gegenüber dem reinen online handel
bestehen und von der digitalisierung
profitieren zu können es braucht
wirklich fairen wettbewerb zwischen
geschäftsmodellen
digitaler großunternehmen und den lokal
verwurzelten unternehmen und 1 geht
nicht das sage ich jetzt auch mal
einrichtungen der kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union weil sie das ja
schon jahrelang immer nicht so wahr
haben wollen es kann nicht sein dass
kleine anzahl einzelhändler händler mehr
steuern in deutschland zahlen als global
agierende versand konzerne damit muss
endlich schluss sein liebe kollegen
kollegen gastes angebot der fairness
und deswegen sitzt auch unser stärkster
kämpfer für den einzelhandel im
kanzleramt des olaf scholz der als
einziger in der bundesregierung vorne
weg gegangen ist um für die globale
mindeststeuer zu kämpfen die union war
nicht dabei urlaubt scholz hat es getan
wo waren sie
einst kann ich ihnen auch nicht ersparen
liefer kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union da haben sie nämlich mit dem
antrag den echten bock geschossen sie
reden und fabulieren den antrag in ihrem
antrag über autofreie innenstädte
abseits der frage wie sinnvoll das
tatsächlich ist da kann man darüber
diskutieren welche für den einzelhandel
wir sie mal zwei zitate von vor wenigen
tagen hier aus der hauptstadt-cdu
vorlesen
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher christian
gräff von der cdu in berlin die
sogenannte flanieren geile meile mit rad
autobahn hat der friedrichstraße weit
mehr geschadet als genutzt ihr kollege
oliver friederici verkehrspolitischer
sprecher der cdu hier in berlin es sei
ein geburtsfehler gewesen die
friedrichstraße nur aus sicht des
radverkehrs zu denken was soll denn nun
gelten frage ich mich entweder ist es
ihre position die darauf abzielt
offensichtlich neuerdings dass ihr rad
oder autofreie innenstädte sich wünschen
oder es ist eben die position der cdu
berlin die sie genau das gegenteil sagen
aber ich finde sie müssen sich mal
entscheiden was sie wirklich wollen das
passt alles nicht zusammen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
einzelhandel in deutschland und unsere
innenstädte stehen vor enormen und
vielfältigen herausforderungen diese
koalition handelt und packt diese
herausforderung an ich freue mich daher
bei diesem thema auf eine gute
zusammenarbeit vielen dank
[Applaus]
darf ich kurz den telefonierenden
kollegen aus der fdp-fraktion bitten
sollte das ein längeres gespräch werden
würden sie bitte den saal verlassen
danke
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion ist
jetzt kai uwe ziegler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kollegen und kollegen
liebe cdu fraktion hat sich ihren antrag
vor ein paar wochen in der planung
gesehen habe dachte ich mir so jahr
präsentiert sich heute der brandstifter
als feuerwehr und
ich kann ihnen sagen ich bin
einzelhändler seit über 30 jahren ich
weiß wovon ich rede
und jemand wie ihre fraktionen die
gerade in den letzten beiden jahren also
massiv knüppel zwischen die beine der
einzelhändler geworfen hat und jetzt
hier öffentlichkeitswirksam auftritt und
die regierung auffordert gehhilfen zu
verteilen das finde ich schon ziemlich
absurd
und wenn ihnen der einzelhandel und die
innenstädte in den letzten jahren auch
nur einen pfifferling wert gewesen wäre
dann hätten sie die sinnlosen lockdown
zur zweijährigen
nicht mit beschlossen und nicht
umgesetzt und es hat sich alles
angeführt für uns da draußen wie ein
großes konjunkturprogramm für den online
handel
und ganz ehrlich als ich an ihren
auftritt denken wenn ich an ihren
auftritt denke am 16.12 letzten jahres
als wir hier in der aktuellen stunde
gefordert haben die 2g regeln für
einzelne abzustatten zu schaffen das war
wirklich ein deutliches zeichen wo sie
stehen und für wen sie stehen für den
einzelhandel die innenstädte jedenfalls
nicht
und ich weiß sie halten diese ganzen
maßnahmen immer noch für gerechtfertigt
aber ich verrate ihnen ein geheimnis
die schweden
trotz keiner gewinner maßnahmen trotz
kein zweig regeln die leben immer noch
und ich glaube es wird auch so bleiben
und wenn ich ihnen noch ein beispiel
geben kann für ihre kompetenz in meinem
wahlkreis war im letzten jahr ihr
wirtschaftsminister unterwegs und
versuchte meinen gegenkandidaten zu
unterstützen
ich würde ihnen empfehlen guckt sich war
das video an das war sehr sehr
spektakulär und der herr altmaier hat
doch versucht anhand seiner magenta
formen krawatten eine symbiose
herzustellen zwischen online und
stationären einzelhandel also wenn sie
mal am wochenende 20 minuten zeit haben
tun sich das angehende altmaier und
töten ein es ist glaube ich ein
highlight auch für sie
und 1 noch ihr antrag
das thema inflation
kam bei ihnen nicht wo haben sie das
nicht ob ich schon was ja jetzt gerade
draußen passiert was das für
auswirkungen ich hab's nicht lesen aber
wahrscheinlich ist das nicht auch nicht
so wichtig und sie wissen es auch nicht
und dann noch eins
ich hatte mir gewünscht dass käme von
ihnen eine zusicherung sie sind jetzt
der opposition dass sie nie wieder bei
2g
sanktionen und bei lok bei uns mitmachen
und wenn sie mitmachen dann vielleicht
wirklich dazu übergehen könnten den
händlern auch eine wirkliche ausstattung
und nicht diese komischen
naja sie nennen das futtermittel also
für mich ist das häufig ganz übel
mogelpackung und vielleicht ja
schadenersatz mal die richtige
richtung aber dazu sind sicherlich
bereit
und ich kann ihnen sagen da draußen im
einzelhandel ist im moment wirklich
katastrophal die umsätze sind deutlich
unter vorkrisenniveau
die menschen draußen gehen nicht in die
städte die nutzen jetzt gerade den
sommer und fahren ein bisschen in den
urlaub und ich kann das auch verstehen
weil es ja nicht wissen was im herbst ja
noch alles passiert
und die kollegen von der cdu so ich
möchte sie auffordert wenn sie mal
wirklich was für einzelne tun nehmen sie
regelmäßig
1000 euro in die hand gehen in ihrer
innenstädte und geben dass bei ihren
einzelnen aus das ist was das können sie
sofort tun und da wollten sich auch alle
in ihren regionen darüber freuen und
das ganze hier betrifft natürlich auch
die fraktion ja auf der linken seite
dummerweise landet dann wahrscheinlich
alles beim textildiscounter und ich
wünsche ihnen ein schönes wochenende
vielen dank
in der bundestag debattiert über einen
antrag der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
impulse für einzelhandel und
innenstädte und mike außendorf von
bündnis 90 die grünen hat jetzt das wort
er ist mitglied im wirtschaftsausschuss
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen der antrag der union und ich
danke ihnen dafür dass sie das hier
heute aufgebracht haben das ist ein sehr
wichtiges thema ist ja hat ja wirklich
interessante anknüpfungspunkte und
insbesondere in der analyse gibt es
große übereinstimmungen zur bedeutung
der innenstädte schreiben richtet ihr
das mal wörtlich weil es wirklich gut
zusammengefasst ist innenstädte mit
einer anziehenden funktionsvielfalt sind
mehr als nur einkaufsstraßen lebendige
und vielfältige innenstädte sind
kulturelles erbe und als ort der
begegnung des zusammenkommens und der
gemeinschaft unverzichtbar für unsere
zusammenleben und den standort
deutschland
gleichzeitig sind sie ohne florierenden
und funktionierenden einzelhandel
undenkbar folgerichtig vollkommene
übereinstimmung und auch der zitierte
handelsverband hat mit seiner
einschätzung einer existenzbedrohenden
lage für viele geschäfte vollkommen
recht auch da geben sie die haltung des
hde hat passend wieder richtet ihr das
nochmal die wiederkehrenden lockt downs
und die damit verbundene verunsicherung
der kunden hätten den einzelhandel so
hart getroffen wie kaum eine andere
branche das herunterfahren des
öffentlichen lebens mit der weitgehenden
monatelange schließung der geschäfte hat
viele handelsunternehmen und
verschuldete not gebracht eigenkapital
und kreditmöglichkeiten sind oftmals
ausgeschöpft so weit der chor doch das
was die korona pandemie jetzt verschärft
und beschleunigt hat das ist doch eine
jahrelange entwicklung und da haben wir
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen und
jetzt schreiben sie in ihrem antrag wir
müssen umdenken und das ist nach 16
jahren regierungszeit etwas spät und
jetzt kommen sie hier mit einem
notizzettel voller in denen so ehrlich
die gäste beim entlastungsgesetz mein
kollege felix donnerstag hat das da
zusammengefasst das klingt so ein
bisschen wie nach dem super hits der
80er 90er jahre aber einmal hin sie
haben als opposition mit diesem antrag
schon ein stand an der stelle
hinzugelernt in der vergangenheit haben
sie immer versäumt auf die finanzierung
einzugehen das haben sich aufgenommen
und immerhin
die bedeutung die erfasst aber sie
schreiben dann das soll sich im rahmen
der zur verfügung stehenden
haushaltsmittel bewegen das was sie mit
ihren 20 punkten fordern also bitte dann
müssen sie auch den nächsten schritt
gehen und sagen wo dann an anderer
stelle eingespart werden soll und noch
ein einsatz zu ihrem gang in die
opposition in den ersten wochen haben
sie ja versucht ihre versäumnisse uns
als ampel anzukreiden jetzt machen sie
neuen schritt sie haben gute ideen ihrer
vorgänger opposition zusammengefasst als
prüfauftrag eingebracht und oben drüber
geschrieben wir denken um also das ist
mal ein interessanter move ich bin
gespannt was da noch so kann ich
in der letzten wahlperiode haben wir als
grüne mit drucksache 19 23 11 6 zum
beispiel ein gesetzentwurf eingebracht
zur verbesserung der situation von
kleinen gewerbemieter erinnern da geht
es um ein verlängerungs recht besseres
kündigungsschutz hätten sie damals
einfach so durchwinken können dann wäre
heute vieles einfacher für die
einzelhändlerin in den straßen
wir haben ich komme jetzt dazu was wir
umgesetzt haben als koalition haben sie
haben schon reagiert
wir haben ja schon reagiert und die
mittel des im letzten in der letzten wp
angestoßenen programms zukunftsfähige
innenstädte und zentren mehr als
verzehnfacht auf 0 250 millionen euro
das ist das was diese koalition bereits
auf den weg gebracht hat außerdem haben
wir die überbrückungshilfe 4 als
zentrales kroner hilfsinstrument bis
juli 2022 verlängert ergänzen das durch
kredite garantien und bürgschaften und
das ist auch eine erleichterung ganz
wesentlich für die händlerinnen in den
innenstädten
auch für digitalisierungs hilfen und
kleinbetriebe und geschäfte sind mittel
im haushalt eingestellt digitalisierung
sprechen sich auch an 25 millionen euro
für das programm go digital alleine
jetzt möchte ich aber noch einen punkt
konkret eingehen hat mein vorredner von
der spd aufgegriffen da verlässt er mich
dann doch der mut sie schreiben einer
sie wollen prüfen inwieweit das konzept
autofreie innenstädte und
gebührenpflichtige parkplätze zur
belebung und steigerung der
aufenthaltsqualität beiträgt aber sie
schreiben gleich eine musste aber auch
gucken und das die besucherfrequenz sich
darunter leitet leidet und die bedeutung
des autos schmälert und da kommt wieder
die alte auto partei cdu hindurch und
der lindemann sie haben ja eben freiburg
und münster als positivbeispiele
angeführten ausgerechnet da haben wir
viel lebensraum umgewandelt viel
straßenraum und lebensraum umgewandelt
und da für sie besonders viel radfahren
und das wäre der richtige weg
übrigens auch die metastudie dass das
difu mit dem fahrrad zum einkaufen
stellt fest in internationalen
vergleichen überall dort wo ich mehr
radfahren in einkaufstraßen bekomme
steigen die umsätze des einzelhandels
und das ist ein ganz zentraler punkt um
die innenstädte zu beleben
es gibt viele weitere beispiele aus new
york aus wien aus hamburg barcelona sie
können sich wirklich überall umgucken
bei der umsetzung der maßnahme sind die
kommunen vielfach weiter als wir hier
auf bundesebene da können wir das
natürlich gerne unterstützen ich dann
mal beispiele in meiner heimatstadt der
gladbach wurde 2020 schon beschlossen
parteiübergreifend damals auch in meiner
stimme im stadtrat die
sondernutzungsgebühren für
außengastronomie und geschäfte
auszusetzen damit sie eben den platz
draußen nutzen können das wird vielfach
genutzt und das ist ganz und wo gerade
schnelle hilfe da sind die kommunen war
schon wirklich sehr weit und das sollten
auch weiter unterstützen
ich komme zum schluss sie sehen also
kommunen in deutschland und weltweit
sind längst weiter die koalition hat
bereits gehandelt und wir werden die
ziele von klimagerechten
menschenfreundlichen in städten mit
hoher aufenthaltsqualität und besseren
bedingungen für den handel weiter
verfolgen danke
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion die
linke pascal leyser
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren in der tat sieht sich
der einzelhandel schon seit jahren
vielfältigen veränderungen ausgesetzt
die massive negative folgen für die
beschäftigten kleine händler und die
innenstädte haben deshalb ist es gut
dass sie von der union die systeme heute
auf die tagesordnung gebracht haben und
die antrag beinhalte dabei durchaus auch
aus unserer sicht diskussionswürdige
vorschläge hat aber auch große
lehrstellen
und auf einige von dem muss ich an
dieser stelle natürlich eingehen
zunächst sie schreiben selbst das ist
die korona pandemie war die das laden
steins handel zuletzt massiv
beschleunigt hat aber darüber welche
mitverantwortung sie dafür tragen
darüber schweigen sie sich
geflissentlich aus es waren doch sie
vorneweg als wirtschaftsminister die in
der großen koalition nicht in der lage
waren hilfsprogramm aufzulegen
tatsächlich einen umfassenden schutz von
kleinen einzelnen einer pandemie bieten
eine kritik übrigens auch von dem von
ihnen ansonsten immer ganz die themen
einzelhandelsverband hde immer wieder
zurecht formuliert wurde bis zuletzt
muss sie nichts daran geändert dass ein
unternehmen einen umsatzausfall von
mindestens 30 prozent verzeichnen musste
um überhaupt unterstützung zu halten
leider haben auch herr habeck und die
ampel koalition daran zuletzt nichts
mehr geändert dabei wissen wir doch alle
das gerade kleine einzelhändler die
unverschuldet von umsatzeinbußen von 20
bis 25 prozent betroffen sind dies nicht
auf dauer verkraften können und viele
lieber ihr geschäft aufgeben bevor sie
in die insolvenz gezwungen werden da
würde ich mir schon ein bisschen mehr
selbstkritik erwünscht
zweitens als läge begrüßte es
ausdrücklich wenn die kommunen gestärkt
werden wenn es um die
eingriffsmöglichkeiten für die stadt-
und raumplanung geht also was wo gebaut
und wofür genutzt werden darf das gilt
liebe kollegin kollegen von der union
ausdrücklich auch für ihre forderungen
das einkaufsgebiet auf der grünen wiese
zu ungunsten der orts und stadtkerne von
den kommunen auch wieder leichter
rückabgewickelt werden können warum sie
hier alle bands die schon gehandelt
haben als sie noch die regierung
gestellt haben würde mich schon
interessieren oder war sie etwa die spd
die blockiert hat das müssen sie schon
mal untereinander nochmal klären und
hier auch vielleicht für alle aufklären
aber auch hier braucht es mehr mut und
da ist natürlich jetzt die neue
bundesregierung gefordert wenn wir
wollen dass dauerhaft leer stehende
geschäfts und büroräume sinnvoll genutzt
werden können dann braucht es auch hier
stärkere eingriffsmöglichkeiten der
kommunen um auch spekulativen leerstand
den gibt es auch beenden zu können und
auch um genauere vorgaben im interesse
der kommunen machen zu können für die
nutzung von gewerbeflächen um bonus
strukturen zu verhindern leben kollegen
drittens das ladensterben hat wie die
union im antrag richtig schreibt sehr
unterschiedliche gründe und auch
regional lokal ist das sehr stark zu
differenzieren auf vieles gehen sie auch
im antrag ein aber worüber sie kein wort
verlieren das ist die situation in
überhitzten immobilienmärkten wie berlin
münchen oder frankfurt wo die
explodierenden gewerbemieten für viele
kleine gewerbetreibende dazu führen dass
diese um ihre existenz bangen müssen und
auch maßgeblich dort zum ladensterben
kleiner gewerbetreibender
beigetragen haben dass die darüber kein
wort verlieren und die
immobilienwirtschaft an dieser stelle
nicht kritisieren das ist bezeichnet
als linke haben wir dazu der vergangenen
statur als erste fraktion konkrete
vorschläge vorgelegt vorgelegt in
angespannten gewerbe mietmärkten
brauchen wir endlich eine mietpreis
bremse für gewerbemieten oder ein
anspruch für gewerbemieter auf
mindestvertragslaufzeit und
der außendorf sie haben das ja auch
angesprochen die grünen haben ja
ähnliche vorschläge macht sie haben
jetzt die union kritisiert dass sie das
in der letzten legislatur nicht gemacht
haben ich erwarte dass die ampel
koalition jetzt dafür sorgt dass auch
die kleinen gewerbemieter endlich
geschützt werden da will ich mal ein
klares bekenntnis zum koalitionsvertrag
findet sich dazu wird es ja nichts ich
hoffe da kommt noch was
eine weitere große leerstelle im antrag
liebe kollegen von der union ist die
perspektive der beschäftigten außer
einer ausweitung der ladenöffnungszeiten
haben sie für diese nichts zu bieten ich
finde das bezeichnend dass sie für
diejenigen die wir alle als heldinnen
und helden des alltags in der pandemie
hier gewertschätzt haben nichts anderes
als längere arbeiten zu lesen haben ich
komme zum schluss was wir tatsächlich
brauchen sind einheitliche
wettbewerbsbedingungen einheitliche
löhne in diesem bereich deswegen muss
dafür gesorgt werden dass endlich wieder
die tarifverträge für den einzelhandel
allgemeinverbindlich erklärt werden
können für den stationären die für den
online handel bei amazon und co vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
pascal maier war das für die linke
impulse für einzelhandel und innenstädte
der antrag der cdu csu wird hier beraten
und man schritt todenhausen von der fdp
ist der nächste redner er ist der
handwerks politische sprecher seiner
frau dann die inflation und jetzt vor
allem die sorgen um die ukraine krise
die wir haben die stimmung der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher schon
lange auf eine harte probe gestellt noch
mehr wurde der stationäre einzelhandel
belastet am anfang dürften wir wegen der
lok downs nicht einkaufen gehen dann
haben die masken pflicht und die kontakt
beschränkungen viele menschen vom
einkaufen abgehalten und nun treiben die
preissteigerungen die ängste auch wenn
geld zum konsum sogar vorhanden ist aber
im frühjahr und im frühjahr die in der
regel eigentlich die lust am einkaufen
steigt findet das derzeit noch nicht so
stadt meine damen und herren wie sehr
hätte ich mir von der cdu diesen antrag
früher gewünscht wie sehr hätte ich mir
diesen antrag in den letzten zwei jahren
gewünscht
als die pandemie dem einzelhandel
deutlich zugesetzt hat da fand nicht
statt sie haben sie haben nicht nur
keinen eigenen antrag gestellt sondern
unsere fdp vorschläge die in die gleiche
richtung gingen ausdrücklich abgelehnt
und wir haben als freie demokraten
direkt nach der bundeswahl gezeigt wie
man sich wirklich für den einzelhandel
einsetzt wir waren es wir waren es die
dafür gesorgt haben dass der
einzelhandel im weihnachtsgeschäft 20 21
offen bleiben durfte dadurch konnte die
geschäfte endlich mal wieder geld
verdienen und hatten die möglichkeit
viele kunden zu bekommen sie als union
haben gegen diese öffnungen gestimmt
viele von ihnen haben stattdessen wieder
mit einem lockdown gedroht gerade
hendrik wüst den ich eigentlich sehr
schätze als vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
war ja ein ganz besonders scharfer
verfechter strengerer maßnahmen gut dass
er sich nicht durchsetzen konnte so
sagen wir endlich wieder offene
geschäfte
cafés restaurants und denn das schöne
ist wir einkaufen geht hat auch zeit zur
pause hat auch zeit für gastronomie denn
die gehören eng zusammen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen fakt ist leider
aktuell aber auch die
verbraucherstimmung ist noch sehr
zurückhaltend auch wenn die menschen
nach aufregung der korona bestimmungen
erstmals seit zwei jahren wieder mehr
freiheit zum einkaufen haben jetzt kommt
ihr in union mit ihrem antrag und ihren
20 forderungen die wir sehr wohl zur
kenntnis genommen haben aber nicht weil
ihre ideen neuwaren nein sondern war
alleine unsere fraktion in den letzten
wahlperiode als sie den
wirtschaftsminister gestellt haben drei
anträge hierzu vorgelegt haben und was
war ihre reaktion peter altmaier gefehlt
sich mehr darin neue corona hilfen für
den geschlossenen einzelhandel zu
beschließen stadt die geschäfte mit
ihren tatsächlich funktionierenden
hygiene und abstands konzepten offen zu
halten und wir haben nicht nur damals
für den einzelhandel unsere stimmung
stimme erhoben sondern wir haben eben
unsere unterstützung auch in dem
koalitionsvertrag
zugesagt und arbeiten gemeinsam in der
koalition an der umsetzung die
herausforderung der zukunft
dekarbonisierung und klimawende
demografischer wandel und
fachkräftemangel sowie digitalisierung
verändertes konsum vorhanden verhalten
das spürt natürlich auch der einzelne da
brauchen wir derzeit nicht nur die
förderung des einzelhandels als solches
sondern eben langfristige strategien wie
sie in den beiden entlastungspaket die
vorgebracht werden und bei der
abschaffung der eeg umlage zum tragen
kommen und gegen die kalte progression
kann ich ihnen sagen hat der
bundesfinanzminister maßnahmen
angekündigt die noch dieses jahr kommen
werden also auch da sind wir auf dem
richtigen weg unser finanzminister hat
die sorgen der bürgerinnen und bürger
der verbraucher auf dem schirm er packt
das an was nötig ist und was möglich ist
meine damen und herren mit der
initiative mit vielen initiativen wird
die bundesregierung auch zusammen mit
den ländern wie für nordrhein westfalen
als gute beispiel mit seinem programm
digital coaches den einzelhandel lokal
und digital zukunftsfit machen da wird
dazu gehört auch die förderung von
digitalisierung schnell im internet für
mehr hybride vertriebswege sie hatten es
gerade angesprochen das ist der weg der
zukunft denn gerade fachgeschäfte also
kleine und mittlere betriebe des
stationären heimischen einzelhandel
müssen in zeiten nach corona im
wettbewerb mit dem handel auf großen
digitalen einkaufsplattform mithalten
können der wettbewerb ist da sehr
starken für mich persönlich gehört dann
allerdings lieber
koalitionspartner es ist meine
persönliche meinung gehört dann
irgendwann auch die lockerungen bei den
öffnungszeiten an sonn und feiertagen
dazu die ladengeschäfte und
entsprechende gastronomie würde dadurch
erheblich gestärkt gestärkt wir wünschen
ich hier wünsche ich mir übrigens mehr
bewegung auch von den
wirtschaftspolitikern der union peter
altmaier
redete viel darüber aber er handelte
nicht das war eine verpasste chance aber
schauen wir nach vorne bei uns bei der
ampel koalition sowie die vermittlung
der einzelhandel in den gut in guten
händen ein es in den besten händen
vielen dank
der nächste redner an der debatte 20 20
maßnahmen schlägt die cdu csu in ihrem
antrag impulse für den einzelhandel in
den innenstädten vor und ulrich lange
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende in dem falls sie
ist abgeordneter hat jetzt 20 kollegen
zunächst freut es uns dass diese debatte
zur prominenter zeit auch von allen
fraktionen entsprechend als notwendig
gewürdigt wird denn natürlich war die
korona pandemie noch mal eine große und
starke belastung für unseren
einzelhandel und wir sehen alle die
verwerfungen in unseren innenstädten
auf der anderen seite und das erlaube
ich mir auch an all die kritiker zu
sagen möchte ich zunächst im
einzelhandel danken und zwar jedem
einzelhändler der während corona für
sicheres einkaufen gesorgt hat mit
masken mit test mit den regelungen ja
wir wollten gesundheit schützen um
einkaufen gehen das war unser ansatz
breit getragen und der war richtig
dankeschön an den einzelhandel an dieser
stelle
und dann liebe kollegen immer das ist
zwar ganz lustig mit dem 16 jahre nur
sie waren zwölf dabei gewann 12 dabei
und acht jahre für den bau zuständig für
den ich hier rede also ich wäre an ihre
stelle da einfach etwas vorsichtiger
sonst müsste man permanent in der
historie von zwölf jahren arbeiten das
bringt nichts lassen sich meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen carsten
linnemann hat sehr eindrucksvoll
persönliche
erlebnisse und das befreiende zahlen
schon da geboten das will ich nicht
wiederholen aber die pandemie war
natürlich ein katalysator sie war ein
brandbeschleuniger für all das was wir
in unseren städten sehen und zwar sowohl
in den ganz großen metropolen aber ganz
hinunter bis in die kleinen städte mit
5000 einwohnern die marktgemeinden wo
wir früher
florierende marktplätze hatten mit
geschäften rundrum wo wir jetzt ein euro
jobs nagel shops oder gar nichts mehr
sehen und genau das ist das was uns
sorge macht und genau hier haben wir und
auch das ist nicht neu in den letzten
jahren immer wieder vorschläge
eingebracht und deswegen auch heute
wollen wir diese
konsequente arbeit mit und für den
einzelhandel fortsetzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der einzelhandel hat aber auch in den
letzten jahren wären corona bewiesen
dass er zu neuen geschäftsideen fähig
ist hat neue konzepte ausprobiert und
einiges hat auch ganz gut funktioniert
und jetzt liegt es an uns
als politik insgesamt und zwar über alle
ebenen den
einzelhandel funktioniert ja nicht nur
von berlin aus oder über die
landesregierung sondern ein bisschen die
kommunalpolitik und deswegen ist es ein
stringenter antrag und auftrag an die
politik insgesamt nicht zuviel
vorzuschreiben sondern vor ort in den
jeweiligen strukturen das zuzulassen was
man im rahmen der kommunalen
selbstverwaltung als notwendig erachtet
[Applaus]
sda das baugesetz geht darum die
benutzten verordnung desto schwieriger
für den einzelhandel vor ort und das ist
genau unsere aufgabe im großen rahmen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
programm zukunftsfähige innenstädte und
zentren wurde angestoßen aus dem
innenministerium und dem bauministerium
heraus wir haben zusammen ja kein
erkenntnis- defiziten in der letzten
periode hatten wir ja lieber kollege
daldrup schon den beirat innenstädte er
seine arbeit aufgenommen hat und viele
ideen geliefert hat es ist also kein
erkenntnis- defizit jetzt muss man
handeln und genau das will unser antrag
impuls zum handeln für unsere
innenstädte liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und lieber kollege außen doch da ist es
auch kein widerspruch zu sagen es gibt
auto freiheit und es gibt auf der
anderen seite erreichbarkeit wenn sie
kleine städte im ländlichen raum haben
brauchen sie erreichbarkeit mit dem auto
da ist der öpnv einem eher
auf der anderen seite müssen sie wissen
wo sie quartiere und plätze schaffen die
autofreie erlebnis zonen sind zum
einkauf zum flanieren zum bleiben und
ihre beispiele wie in barcelona hamburg
die passen jetzt nicht bei mir zur
donauwörth oettingen oder dillingen an
der donau das ist anders oder könnte
jeder kollege seine städte genau so
nenne ich
würde einfach mal einen persönlichen rat
geben statt der bio gemüse kiste mit dem
diesel transport vor der tür auf dem
wochenmarkt gehen regional einkaufen das
was es jetzt gibt frischen spargel
frische erdbeeren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind am wochenende im
wahlkreis es kann doch jeder tun und
dann auch noch mal bei seinem
bekleidungshändler vorbei das einzel
haben wir das ist regionalität das ist
lebensqualität tun wir es doch alle wir
stärken damit gemeinschaft und
einzelhandel
die benutzten verordnung das baugesetz
habe ich angesprochen die
städtebauförderung auf
städtebauförderung bringt leuchttürme in
die stadt deswegen liebe neue regierung
für die nationalen projekte der städte
baus keine frischen mittel einzustellen
ist der erste fehler für und wie
innenstädte und gegen die entwicklung in
unseren städten korrigieren inzwischen
weisen und dritter lesung wir haben
einen antrag vorgelegt viele ideen wir
freuen uns auf die diskussion sie ist es
allemal wert danke 5
franziska mushak spd fraktions die
nächste rednerin der debatte
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren mehr kunst mehr
kultur mehr soziales in die innenstädte
ganz ehrlich großartig mein herz geht
auf wissen sie ich komme aus der
kreativwirtschaft und aus der sozialen
arbeit da ging es mir fiel um die
entwicklung von ortszentren mit
jugendarbeit gemeinschaftliches leben
kunst und kultur und besonders
demokratisches mitwirken
die einleitung ihres antrags und mein
bisheriger beruf haben also eins
gemeinsam wie sie es schon gesagt haben
endlich leben in die bude bringen
großartig
doch die vorschläge sind bekannt sie
werden schon seit sehr langer zeit von
der progressiven zivilgesellschaft
angebracht aber wobei die union in den
letzten 16 jahren um diese punkte
aufzugreifen städte in denen das
wirklich gut gelingt sind progressiv
regiert erfurt magdeburg chemnitz kiel
mannheim die liste könnte weitergehen
zur ruhe gewerbe mieten und
immobilienpreise verhindern dass mit
kultur und sozialen orten endlich leben
in die innenstädte kommt dass eine kita
sich ansiedeln kann das mehr
generationen heute entstehen oder dass
man kleine räume für kunst oder modernes
arbeit mieten kann leider lassen sie den
punkt gewerbemieten im antrag völlig
unbekannt und wieder stellt sich mir die
frage wo war die union in den letzten 16
jahren wenn es um die regulieren und
regulierung von gewerbemieten ging und
wo ist die union heute wenn es darum
geht kultur kreativ und sozial
wirtschaft zu unterstützen
gleichzeitig schreiben sie dass
öffnungszeiten aufgeweicht werden und
mir mehr verkaufsoffene sonntage möglich
sein sollen wenn jemand tatsächlich bei
mir in der kleinen stadt dieses passende
personal dafür finden würde müsste es ja
auch anständig bezahlt werden das können
sich nur die großen handelsketten
leisten und die gibt es schon zu genüge
in unseren großstädten unseren kleinen
städten hilft das überhaupt nicht dabei
müsste das angebot unsere innenstädte
doch viel bunter und vielfältiger werden
vielmehr würde es die arbeitsbedingungen
im handel noch einmal verschärfen und
verschlechtern und die berufe noch
unattraktiver für junge menschen machen
sie glauben doch nicht dass sich durch
längere öffnungszeiten auch nur ein
prozent vom online-handel wieder zurück
verlagert das haben sie ihr selbst in
ihrem antrag so beschrieben dass es ein
zurück nicht geben wird und jetzt
versuchen sie es geht und wie doch aber
ich finde etwas hilflos sie schreiben
dass die kommunen die digitalisierung
voranbringen sollen ich finde diese
forderung recht frech wenn ich die
schwierige personallage und die
finanzielle situation zum beispiel
meiner stadt anschaue wie sollen denn
gerade ländliche regionen das alleine
leisten bevor sie von den kommunen die
digitalisierung verschiedener
lebensbereiche einfordern brauchen diese
doch erst einmal eine stabile und
schnelle internetverbindung und dann auf
das qualifizierte personal und wo war
die union in den letzten 16 jahren wenn
es um den ausbau des breitbands ging ich
fürchte sie haben noch vieles aus ihrer
vorherigen regierungszeit aufzuarbeiten
und vor allem empfehle ich ihnen ihren
werten parteikollegen in sachsen mal von
ihren großartigen ideen zu erzählen die
erlebe ich nämlich auf kommunaler und
auf landesebene ganz anders
ehrlicherweise
hatte ich noch nie den eindruck dass der
union städte besonders wichtig sind
abgesehen von ihrem wert als
wirtschaftsstandort dass man dort gut
und gerne und bezahlbar leben kann
irgendwie nebensache hauptsache die
wirtschaft sieht sich an der rest der
wird dann schon aber sehen sie so
umfunktioniert dass licht das können sie
überall beobachten erst kommen die
kreativen werten die quartiere auf dann
siedeln sich geschäfte an und dann
profitiert davon die wirtschaft sie
schreiben dass die unionsgeführte
bundesregierung das bundesprogramm
zukunftsfähige innenstädte und zentren
angestoßen habe sie vergessen dabei und
das wurde heute auch schon gesagt dass
um ganz sicher nicht mit böser absicht
dass dabei erstmal nur 25 millionen euro
von ihnen zur verfügung gestellt wurden
und dann die spd mit dem damaligen
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz dem
beitrag verzehnfacht hat
jetzt stellen sie forderungen an unsere
kunden ist er in klara geywitz dabei ist
sie doch schon längst dran mit dem
beirat innenstädte trafen sich anfang
jahr
2022 sie können gerne zuhören mit den
kommunen wird die ministerin sich im
juli 22 zu diesem thema austauschen und
die innenstadt strategie wird ständig
weiterentwickelt sie sehen ihr antrag
ist noch nicht ganz ausgereift deshalb
lade ich sie ein lassen sie uns
gemeinsam die zukunft der innenstädte
gestalten lassen sie uns gemeinsam die
voraussetzungen schaffen dass menschen
mit dem bus mit dem fahrrad oder der
bahn in die innenstädte kommen lassen
sie uns daran arbeiten kleinere
innenstädte interessanter und
lebenswerter zu machen ich bin gespannt
auf die debatten in den ausschüssen
vielen dank und ein herzliches glückauf
franziska masche war das für die spd die
union hat den antrag vorgelegt impulse
für einzelhandel und innenstädte und
fordert unter anderem
in abstimmung mit den bundesländern
solle geprüft werden ob eine
anlassbezogene ausweitung von
ladenöffnungszeiten deutliche impulse
für den innerstädtischen einzelhandel
setzen können für die afg enrico kommt
wieder stehen wir heute hier wieder
diskutieren wir über einen ihrer anträge
bei denen man sich fragen muss warum sie
das nicht schon in ihrer regierungszeit
die letzten 16 jahre gemacht haben ja
ich weiß sie können es nicht mehr hören
aber sie werden sich immer wieder
anhören müssen
gestern haben es ihnen schon
habe ich ihnen schon gesagt herr spahn
hat gestern erwidert es habe ja an der
spd gelegen umso lustiger ist es heute
dass die spd ihnen dieselben vorhalte
macht die sie der spd machen ja da frage
ich mich wer hat ihn zusammen reagierte
altmaier im cdu ministerium herr scholz
das finanzministerium jetzt schieben sie
sich gegenseitig den schwarzen peter zu
ich glaube die politik die sie beide
zusammen zu verantworten haben was
schlechte politik und das muss hier
heute mal deutlich ausgesprochen werden
und wenn sie liebe cdu tatsächlich
vernünftige politik machen wollen und
die antrag von gestern und auch der
antrag von heute die sind ja im grunde
genommen gar nicht schlecht dann frage
ich mich warum ihren sie denn immer
wieder hin zum politisch linken spektrum
warum warum schauen sie denn nicht mal
auf die marktwirtschaftliche seite denn
das was sie hier heute fordern der
linnemann verlustverrechnung sie haben
es angesprochen
das haben wir die gesamte letzte
legislatur gefordert also orientieren
sie sich lieber zum
marktliberalen zu marktwirtschaftlichen
spektrum hier im bundestag und nicht
immer nach links aber
kurz auch vielleicht noch zum antrag ich
habe leider nur drei minuten in dem ziel
was dieser was dieser antrag verfolgt
sind wir uns einig der stationäre
einzelhandel ist natürlich mehr als
handel weil er eben die innenstädte auch
gesellschaftlich und kulturell prägt das
besondere interesse an einem
florierenden einzelhandel ist also
tatsächlich mehr als wirtschaftspolitik
der dramatische verlust an markt teilen
gegenüber dem online handel es aber zu
einem großen teil geben auch hausgemacht
eben durch die eben angesprochene
politik die steuerliche benachteiligung
schreit doch zum himmel amazon zahlt in
deutschland keinen cent steuern wie kann
das sein wie kann es sein dass gegenüber
einem kleinen fachgeschäft betreiber in
deutschland ohne steuerberater faktisch
derjenige nicht existieren kann amazon
liebe kollegen ist doch nicht gestern
erst vom himmel gefallen und auch ihre
forderung nach einem bürokratischen
beratungs moratorium und mutet schon
fast komisch an waren es doch die
regierungen unter unionsführung die
milliarden euro zusätzlicher bürokratie
kosten dem handel in dem letzten
jahrzehnt aufgebürdet haben der
online-handel will und soll nicht wieder
sterben für viele menschen gerade im
ländlichen raum ist er eben die rettung
der stationäre handel muss nur die
gleichen chancen bekommen und gute
unternehmerische ideen dazu gibt es
genug vielen dank
caroline orte bündnis 90 die grünen sind
nix rednerin hinter dem berg
[Applaus]
vergab frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen gute
lebensverhältnisse in unseren städten
das heißt mit menschen an schönen orten
zusammen kommen und gut versorgt zu sein
mit den dingen des alltäglichen lebens
attraktive und lebenswerte innenstädte
sind der ort an dem gute kommunale
gemeinschaft leben wohnen und arbeiten
möglich ist
doch so wichtig innenstädte für
gemeinschaft vor ort sind aktuell
verändern sie sich vielerorts rapide der
discount rennt rasant steigende
immobilienpreise durch die panini
nochmals zunehmende online handel sind
die wesentlichen treiber
leerstände und verfallene infrastruktur
prägen zu oft unsere kleinen städte aber
auch die quartiere in den größeren
städten
in diesem punkt niveau union haben sie
recht und sie müssen einräumen dass
veränderungen dringend notwendig ist
aber bitte nicht mit den alten plänen
und rezepten von vorgestern das leben in
unseren städten von heute das braucht
ideen und konzepte für integrierte und
nachhaltige stadtentwicklung
mit der förderung des traditionellen
einzelhandels ist es nicht mehr getan
wer dafür sorgen will dass auch in
zukunft autos den platz und unseren den
interessen und jedes gefühl von lebens
lebensqualität wortwörtlich im keim
ersticken der ist im letzten jahrhundert
hängen geblieben die innenstadt mit
zukunft die braucht eine
verkehrsentlastung durch klimaneutrale
mobilität die autogerechte stadt die
hilft auch nicht im ländlichen raum
eine stärkere mischnutzung und kleinere
läden das ist in stadt der zukunft die
innenstadt mit zukunft sorgt dafür dass
menschen
mehr vorfinden als nur die möglichkeit
zu konsumieren wir brauchen plätze für
alle mit freiraum für kinder und
jugendliche mit platz für
bürgerschaftliches engagement mit platz
für erholung und begegnung und liebe
union ja ein stück weit beschreiben sie
diese punkte in ihrem antrag es klingt
auch durch das die von diesem konzept
nicht einmal gehört haben freut mich es
stellt sich nur die frage warum und das
wurde heute schon öffentlich oft
angesprochen und ich frage mich trotzdem
entsprechende änderungen beispielsweise
der städtebauförderung in den letzten 16
jahren von ihrer fraktion entweder
verbaselt oder vehement blockiert wurden
in ihrem antrag fordern sie zum beispiel
die förderung von grünflächen und
zusätzliche klimaschutz und
anpassungsmaßnahmen
dass der klimawandel in form von
hitzewellen und überschwemmungen auch
unsere innenstädte betrifft das ist
keine ganz neue erkenntnis
klimaschutz steigert lebensqualität in
unseren städten mit klimaanpassung
schützen wir sensible gruppen und
kritische infrastruktur liebe union es
ist unglaubwürdig
glaubwürdigkeit das schafft man am
besten durch tun
deshalb hat das umweltministerium
letzten monat sein programm für die
kommunale klimaanpassung verlängert und
durch die förderung von klima anpassungs
manager innen sinnvoll ergänzt
klimaanpassung wird so zu einer
realistischen seinem realistischen
aufgabenfeld für unsere städte und
gemeinden und das ist ein wichtiger
schritt
und erkannte koalition haben wir noch
einiges vor in den kommenden jahren dazu
gehört vor allem auch die beschleunigung
von planungs vorhaben und der abbau der
richtlinien die nachhaltigkeit und
vielfalt in unseren innenstädten zurzeit
noch erschweren hier ist ein guter
interessensausgleich notwendig deshalb
müssen wir diese maßnahmen sorgsam
prüfen
aber es ist auch jetzt schon klappt mit
der ampel werden unsere innenstädte
lebendiger wir stärken das nebeneinander
von bars geschäften clubs und cafés
beispielsweise durch die geplante
novelle des immissionsschutzgesetzes
in vielen kleineren städten und bereitet
der leerstand in den innenstädten große
sorgen beim prüfen ob dem mit einer
erneuerung des vorkaufsrechts für
kommunen und einer engen verzahnung
zwischen bebauungsplänen und
flächennutzungsplänen begegnet werden
kann
wir wollen für serien die vielfältige
und lebendige innenstädte und in der
ampelkoalition bringen wir hierzu mit
dem neuen haushalt einiges auf dem weg
denn am ende können nur dort wo die
kommunen genug finanziellen spielraum
haben innenstädte vorangebracht werden
es ist deshalb zentral dass die ampel
sich der verschlafenen aufgabe stellt
die kommunen endlich finanziell ihren
herausforderungen angemessen
auszustatten
hierbei sind schon einige schritte
unternommen worden es gibt zusagen für
die geflüchteten finanzierung die
verstetigung des höheren anteils an den
kosten der unterkunft das zügige und
entschlossener an fassende altschulden
frage das sind alles wichtige schritte
es braucht aber noch
substanziell mehr geld für den
kommunalen klimaschutz eine
weiterführung des finanziellen
engagement des bundes für die
kinderbetreuung und eine deutliche
vereinfachung unseres fördersystems ich
freue mich darauf dass wir auch diese
punkte gemeinsam als ampel auf den weg
bringen werden
ihr antrag liege union zeigt in jedem
fall er die versäumnisse der letzten
jahre auch als dass er uns wirklich
voranbringt wir als amt stärken jetzt
schon in diesem jahr mit diesem haushalt
sport der im jugendzentrum freizeit und
kultureinrichtungen
senioren und begegnungsstätten
sollten ihren konzepten fall erlauben
sie doch eine zwischenfrage des kollegen
lange
sollten konzepte ein dann kommen sie
aber bitte zum schluss ihrer rede zeit
ist vorbei okay die abende regierung
wird an vielen schrauben drehen für eine
stärkung der kommunen und eine
stadtentwicklung für die innenstädte der
zukunft das erwarten unsere städte und
gemeinden zu recht ich freue mich darauf
diese aufgaben anzufassen
und zu einer kurzintervention anteilig
des voi lange
sehr geehrte frau kollegin ok
ich empfehle ihnen mal einen austausch
mit den kollegen der druck von der spd
mit dem wir ja zwölf jahre zusammen
regiert haben die städtebauförderung die
sie vorhin angesprochen haben
insbesondere die vereinfachung und die
themen stadtgrün haben wir in der
letzten periode zu neuen programmen
zusammengefasst flexibler gemacht das
was sie hier genannt haben finden sie
heute schon in den programmen
informieren sie sich mal bei ihren
kommunen in der kommunalpolitik welche
umsetzungsmöglichkeiten da gibt kann man
auch klimamanager davon mit bezahlen da
bereits vorgenommen werden wenn sie das
thema ansprechen
kultur jugend sport dann empfehle ich
ihnen darauf hinzuwirken in der
koalition das programm jugend sport
kultur wieder aufzulegen wenn ich den
haushalt richtig im kopf habe wird es
nur aus finanziert und ist nicht mehr
neu enthalten dann setzen sie doch
tatsächlich wenn sie jetzt regieren das
um was sie uns hier als versäumnis
vorhalten wir haben es gemacht sie sind
denn sie können die antworten
vielen dank für den hinweis keine sorge
mit händedruck bin ich in gutem kontakt
genauso wie mit unseren städten und
gemeinden und landkreisen ich komme
selber aus der kommunalpolitik selber
aus der kommunalen verwaltung ich glaube
der informationsfluss steht dankeschön
klaus peter willsch ist der nächste
redner der in der debatte von der
fraktionen cdu/csu
dankeschön zwar auch präsidentin meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren liebe
kollegen
kollege lange hat ja gerade mal richtig
gestellt frau otte was da die ihren
äußerungen korrekt korrektur würde ich
war und ich sag mal darüber hinaus auch
mit auf den außen darauf eingehen wie
sie mit diesem bisschen auto bashing und
ein bisschen mehr wohlfühlen das ist ja
nicht getan wir müssen wirklich vor ort
lösungen finden die passen zu den leuten
und dann ist es wichtig dass man auch
plätze erreichen kann ich habe gerade
heute wieder telefoniert mit meiner frau
gesagt morgen habe ich wieder
dreiviertelstunde vor dieser fahrt einer
ampel gestanden um noch in die stadt
rein zu kommen weil dann grün der
verkehrsdezernent ihre vorstellungen
durchsetzen will die däninnen im
innenstadthandel nachhaltig schaden
ich meine auch wenn die letzten dann
sich nun aufmachen trotz inflation und
wer trotz und nach pandemie überwindung
und in einer situation wo man vielleicht
beim wetter her wieder luftig einkaufen
zu gehen dann sagen sie bitte auch ihre
militanten außen gruppen davon der
letzten generation abidi heißen dass es
sich nicht nur festkleben sollen auf den
straßen damit die leute wenigstens
hinkommen zu den leben und nicht
abgehalten werden von denen die da
meinen sie alle erzählen in ihrem sinne
ich werde ganz zu begeben noch ein
habeck erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
herr kollege will ich fordere sie auf
dass sie richtig stellen dass die
gruppen die sich der angesprochen haben
die straßen blockieren keine militanten
außen gruppen von bündnis 90 die grünen
sind und dass hier an dieser stelle zur
wahrheit zurückkommen vielen dank
dass
dann ist das vielleicht eine
fehlwahrnehmung von mir gewesen aber ich
habe noch nicht viele kräftige
aussagen gehört die sich distanziert
hätten von diesem freiheits
beschränkenden und und
rechtsstaatswidrig verhalten was wir da
jeder trainer flughafen zu fahren
amstätter eingehen und was weiß ich wo
überall machen sie es machen sie es
deutlich sie haben hier jetzt schon mal
beitrag dazu geleistet lassen der
bundesvorstand der fraktion beschließen
er heftige distanzierung davon und
aufruf dieser drucken da endlich wieder
an rechtsstaatlichem boden
zurückzukommen und dann bin ich bereit
gehende alle hände zu reichen die wir
zur verfügung stehen
ich will um auch um auch erst einmal ein
wird menschlich ist signal zu senden wir
haben gerade gehört dass der kollege
habe ich wollte der minister nicht dabei
sein kann weil er positiv getestet wir
hoffen dass ein symptomfreien verlauf
hat denn so läuft wie bei mir ich hab es
kurz vor weihnachten dann ist es gut das
wünschen wir ihm auch und nehmen das
auch natürlich entsprechend positiv zur
kenntnis dass sie uns hier
informieren darüber ich will
noch einmal ganz kurz weil fach licht
also sowohl das menschliche der
persönlichen betroffenheit dass carsten
linnemann geschildert hat geschildert
hat als auch dass das städtebauliche
entwicklungspolitischer was eigentlich
langer noch mal sehr deutlich
klargestellt hat
nochmal an 1 appellieren versuchen sie
doch mal wirklich das leben mit
deutschland so zu nehmen wie es ist
in deutschland leben fast 60 prozent in
einheiten unter 50.000 mein wahlkreis
rheingau taunus limburg der ist
deutschland so ist deutschland größte
stadt 36.000 einwohner und da sind schon
die stadtteile mitgezählt und dann ist
das 180 da verteilt und da können sie
nicht mit ihrem one fits all lösung auto
bashing und was weiß ich was kommen wenn
sie den lebenswirklichkeit der menschen
gerecht werden wollen dann müssen sie
ein bisschen mehr bieten und müssen ein
bisschen mehr sich den menschen zuwenden
in ihrer konkreten lebenssituation ich
muss leider
ich komme dann aber dazu den positiven
abbinden auch auf die kollegin wasik
nummer 1 gehen das hat nämlich gezeigt
worauf wir in dieser großen koalition
immer rücksicht nehmen mussten sobald
das thema ladenöffnungszeiten überhaupt
nur angedacht wird kommt schon diese von
gewerkschaften infizierte
gegenreaktionen gottes welt abbau von
arbeitnehmerrechten
das ist auch nicht die
lebenswirklichkeit reden sie denn mal
mit menschen die jeden einzelhandel aber
wir haben keine probleme sondern das zu
besetzen wenn sie sonntags mal aufmachen
können weil die leute gerne arbeiten die
da der teilzeit wieder teilzeit und
geringfügig beschäftigt sind aber das
wollen sie das wollen sie nicht zur
kenntnis nehmen sie wollen sich nicht
stören lassen in ihrem ideologischen
gerüst durch aspekte aus der
lebenswirklichkeit
ich hab' ich hab' ich habe
wahrgenommen das hat toten hausen sich
nochmal an dem vista formal
verkündeten freedom day abgearbeitet hat
in seiner argumentation aber ich musste
1 zusammenfassend feststellen ich habe
selten erlebt dass ein antrag so viel
übereinstimmung im ganzen haus gefunden
hat von allen seiten ist er gelobt
worden die einnahmen gesagt kopien pace
die anderen haben gesagt hätten wir
alles schon gemacht werden weil gekonnt
hätten die können jetzt also ich habe
große hoffnung dass wir mit großer einen
großen einvernehmen hier diesen antrag
der cdu csu annehmen denn nach all dem
was jetzt schon positiv dazu gesagt
worden das kann ich mir gar nichts
anderes mehr vorstellen
ich lade sie dazu herzlich ein das
diskutieren denn unsere innenstädte sind
es wert wir haben doch eine wende wenn
man denkmalschutz denken was macht das
für einen sinn wenn da niemand mehr
hingeht weil sie sich bei lohnstein so
geht es müssen erlebnisräume seien die
innenstädte die ortskerne und dann muss
man auch den kommunen die luft lassen
das zu entscheiden vor ort wie sie es
für richtig halten sie wollen bürokratie
entlasten gehen sie ist da an schaffen
sie diese unseligen stundenzettel ab die
die leute abends ausfüllen haben sie
bitte zu schützen rät stehen sie
überlegen sie mal nicht mit der
genehmigungs fiktion arbeiten kann bei
umbauten bei genehmigungs bei
genehmigungspflichtigen
angelegenheiten für den einzelhandel
denn das hatte
und danke der präsident noch mal ganz
herzlich für eure geduld
helfen sie mit helfen sie mit dass wir
die innenstädte lebendig halten und das
das wird deren unterstützung jetzt
zuteil werden lassen fiel wieder
aufbauen könnten
klaus peter willsch war das aus der
unionsfraktion hier mit seiner rede wie
die innenstädte der einzelhandel in den
innenstädten attraktiv gestaltet werden
kann und unterstützt werden kann auf den
antworten wird es johannes alt von der
emission soll die gemeinde der zukunft
aussehen und lieber herr wild ich habe
700 dürfen am wahlkreises auch der
ländliche raum ist das zeichen wichtiger
aspekt da stimme ich ihnen zu nachdem
wir heute bereits über viele
detailfragen geredet haben und
vorschläge aus ihrem antrag dann ist es
doch jetzt so sich zum ende debatte
nochmals struck zurücktreten möchte und
ein paar grundsätzliche erwägungen in
den blick nehmen möchte stellen sie sich
vor wir müssten die städte die
grundzentren die mittelzentren die
oberzentren neu planen neu denken wie
würden wir das heute machen da kann die
lösung jetzt auch nicht sein dass wir
nur an den symptomen ansätzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
viele dinge sind richtig die sie dort in
ihrem antrag haben aber es doch zu sehr
von dem geist des konservieren zustrom
hier ein schräubchen den schräubchen ich
glaube wir müssen da ein bisschen größer
denken und wenn wir an die innenstädte
denken die funktions getrennte
innenstadt die allein dem einzelhandel
dient ist eine entwicklung der
nachkriegszeit gucken wir uns die
stadtentwicklung 1900 dann sehen wir
dort viertel nicht gelebt gearbeitet und
konsumiert wurde und diese funktion
mischung sollte uns orientierung seien
innovative modelle müssen hierher
wie sollte also die stadt der zukunft
aussehen während der pandemie so zeigen
es befragung standen für über 60 prozent
der innenstadtbesucher begegnungen im
vordergrund gefolgt von dem wunsch den
einzelhandel zu unterstützen und café
und restaurant besuchen wir wissen also
was für menschen innenstädte attraktiv
macht vielfalt da sollten sie sich
vielfältiger aufstellen mit wohnen leben
arbeiten gastronomie als ensemble und
mit kurzen wegen und dies nicht allein
im stadtzentrum
letzte woche hat euch auf einer
berichterstatter reise nach schweden und
dänemark die gelegenheit zu sehen wie
einer alten industriestadt landskrona
mit konsequenter stadtentwicklung ein
neuanfang gewagt wurde vor sozial
problematische viertel durch verlegung
von verkehrswegen von einer randlage in
die mitte der stadt gerückt neue
attraktive townhouses werden zwischen
vormalige sozialwohnungen gebaut und mit
schulen und einkaufsmöglichkeiten
ergänzt um soziale segregation abzubauen
und neue steuer kräftige bürger in die
stadt zu locken dies braucht aber auch
vor allen dingen mut mut ebenen
übergreifend zusammenzuarbeiten und
ganzheitliche entscheidung für eine
gemeinde zu treffen
fragen wir nach der zukunft der stadt
und der gemeinde sollten wir keineswegs
den ländlichen raum vergessen was
dorfzentrum der zukunft ist genauso
richtigen das könnte ein gebäude sein
dass die unterschiedlichsten funktionen
unter einem dach versammelt vom netz
nehmen wir coworking spaces neben der
möglichkeit zu arbeiten sind dass orte
der begegnung orte der kultur und orte
der bildung
seiner letzten rede habe ich ihnen von
den dörfern aber im wahlkreis berichtet
wo man oft auf einen apfelbaum steigen
muss um netz empfangen zu haben dort ist
die einzige vorhandene öffentliche
infrastruktur oft die bushaltestelle und
der briefkasten an der kein bus fährt
übrigens der bushaltestelle und jetzt
guckt uns gerade eine junge gründerin
aus einem dorf bei waren zu die gerade
gestern mit ganz ganz viel eigenem
engagement ihren coworking space deck
gegründet hat um ihrem dorf eine mitte
zurückzugeben ein coworking mit
besprechungs flächen im aufnahmestudio
für videos und für ton für unternehmen
und auch ein dorfladen mit einem café
mit einem 24 stunden zugang elektronisch
vollkommen innovativ hier könnten auch
noch andere dienstleistungen wie post
und andere einzelhändler andocken also
es geht nicht nur um fördermittel allein
sondern innovations- und gründergeist
für unsere dörfer und ich danke heute
katharina scheunemann für alle die hier
fuhren alle in alle die eine initiative
haben ihr land leben zu bereichern für
diesen steinigen weg den sie geht um
ihre heimat neu aufzustellen
die ampel koalition hat bereits einige
weichen gestellt dort büros und co
working spaces werden als teil der
daseinsvorsorge
anerkannt und zusätzlich gefördert im
programm für den küstenschutz und ja wir
erleben aktuell eine schwere krise der
innenstädte und ortskerne doch gibt es
diese krise zugleich auch die
möglichkeit die stadt der zukunft zu
denken dieser fordert mut mut vor ort
durch konsequente anwendung des
planungsrechts sowie eine
unbürokratische zusammenarbeit wir
sollten darüber nachdenken die über
komplexe förderlandschaft zu
vereinfachen programme zusammenzuführen
zu digitalisieren und somit auch für
kleine städte und gemeinden den aufwand
der beantragen zu begrenzen dies könnte
unser beitrag seien die städte und
gemeinden zur zukunft zu befähigen ich
freue mich auf die beratung ihres
antrags im wirtschaftsausschuss vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
johannes alt aus der spd hat ist eben
angedeutet dieser antrag wird nach
dieser debatte an die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen und der
wirtschaftsausschuss ist hat
federführend vorher gibt es aber noch
einen redner und das ist hagen reinhold
von den liberalen
präsidenten liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen also auch ich danke der union
verdient vorgelegten antrag und ich
danke dir noch wegen der anderen sache
nämlich dass sie ganz selbstständig ihre
versäumnisse der letzten jahre auf
arbeitet das entlastet uns als jetzige
regierung von dieser aufgabe mir wäre es
zu viele seelen striptease ehrlich ich
würde hier mit hochroten kopf und mit
schweiß auf der stirn stehen sie haben
versierte redner geschickt ihnen das
nicht passiert ist das ist gut deshalb
ließ sich dieser antrag im übrigen auch
wie abgeschrieben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag war da stehen ja die
versäumnisse ihrer regierungszeit drin
und das was dieses land jetzt braucht
deshalb ist es sich nämlich so schade
schade dass das umdenken was ihr antrag
geschrieben haben jetzt erst kommt ganz
ehrlich dieses umdenken das hätte nicht
schon vor sechs monaten sondern vor
jahren passieren müssen bei dem internet
wo ich mich immer ein weder gibt es hier
online handel seit vielen vielen jahren
hätte ihnen auch vorher einfallen können
jetzt herlinde waren sie sagen keine
verantwortung wegschieben die cdu
landesminister wenn vorbildlicher weise
stadtrat ladenöffnungszeiten geschrieben
in dem antrag entdecken sie ja ihre
freude zur liberalisierung der
ladenöffnungszeiten selbst sonntags und
bäder region angesprochen ich komme aus
dem tourismusland nicht seit jahrzehnten
an dass wir die leute zum geburtstag
einladen und so dass keine torte
hinstellen er ich hab dann probleme aber
jetzt mal zu ihrer verantwortung denn
nicht nur zu recht die gewerkschaften
sind fürs personal machen sie sich stark
in meinem bundesland ist es immer wieder
die union die sagt der kirche hat muss
am sonntag möglich sein story aus bayern
ich glaube in bayern regieren sie da
gibt es ein geiles modell das nennt sich
josefs nahkauf box total geiles ding
digitalisierung zusammengebracht
arbeitskräftemangel verhindert laden der
ohne personal funktioniert der darf in
ihrem regierten bayern sonntags nicht
öffnen einnahmen ohne personal verboten
in bayern das ist also das wahre wesen
der union
ich darf
auch wenn es mir auf der seele brennt
nichts weiter über den lockdown den
erkenntnissen die sie gewonnen haben die
haben sie jetzt niedergeschrieben aber
eine sache die muss ich erwähnen war da
schlägt dem fass den boden aus und zwar
gehörig
pumpt reizen dieses antrages greift
einen antrag auf eine schließung antrag
der letzten legislatur diesen hohen haus
ist da geht es um die änderung der
baunutzungsverordnung eine neue idee der
durchmischung der stadt neues
zusammenleben der stadt da kämpfen
parlament aber über alle bänke hinweg
jahre lang an einem thema wofür ihr
minister horst seehofer und seehofer ein
paar aus dem kabinett aus dem alten
sitzen ja noch hier nie offen haben
immer wieder hat das ministerium als
abgeblockt alle parlamentarier fast alle
fast alle parlament beschließen ein
entschließungsantrag dass die regierung
aufgefordert wird noch in der letzten
legislatur die baunutzungsverordnung zu
ändern seehofer macht alles nur durch
das was das parlament will und jetzt
haben sie die frechheit sich
hinzustellen und zu sagen diese
baunutzungsverordnung soll jetzt sofort
umgesetzt natürlich stehen das im
koalitionsvertrag war es ein richtiger
schritt ist und wir werden das als ampel
auch machen aber so dreist hier
aufzutreten dass ich ihnen nicht
durchgehen
nachdem seelen striptease
nachdem seelen striptease kommt ja noch
was anderes das wesen der union
verändert sich gerade das müssen wir
auch mal deutlich sagen für alle die
kommunalpolitik machen sonst war die
union ja in einer partei die auch die
kommunale selbstverwaltung hoch gehalten
hat sind wir auch und jetzt lese ich in
diesem antrag dass wir also mit ge und
verboten in den kommunen stark agieren
sollen am besten aus dem bundestag und
zwar mit gebührenfreien parkplätzen also
ich habe nichts gegen gebührenfreie
parkplätze aber wenn wir jetzt anfangen
für jede kommune deutschlands im
bundestag über gebührenfreie parkplätze
zu diskutieren der hat den aufbau
unserer republik noch nicht verstanden
und nicht verstanden dass wir guten
kommunalpolitiker haben sie das die
stadt in jedem einzelfall bestens allein
erscheinen können ich freue mich ich
freue mich selbsterkenntnis ist der
erste schritt zur besserung hat mein
vater mir gesagt haben recht gehabt
diese selbsterkenntnis haben sie als
gewonnen dazu gratuliere ich ihnen
herzlich deshalb wird wahrscheinlich die
zusammenarbeit was dieses thema betrifft
in dieser legislatur ganz wunderbar
funktionieren und alle koalitions
anträge den nächsten monaten werden sie
konzipieren schloss geht ich komme zum
schluss bedanke mich für die möglichkeit
dieser tollen rede wünschen uns einen
schönen nach bedachten
hagen reinhold bedankt sich für die
möglichkeit dieser tollen rede das ist
auf ein schönes schlusssatz für diese
debatte zu den impulsen für einzelhandel
und innenstädte auf antrag der cdu csu
fraktion und damit kommen wir zum
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt da geht es
wieder einmal kann man sagen in energie
die energie und energiesicherheit
spielte in dieser sitzungswoche ja schon
das ein oder andere mal eine rolle denn
natürlich ist durch den angriff
russlands auf die ukraine klar die lage
ist angespannt und so möchten die
fraktionen von spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp
das energie sicherungs gesetz ändern das
wird hier angezeigt mit energie
sicherungs gesetz
1975 denn in dieser zeit wurde es in den
70er jahren
formuliert damals noch als reaktion auf
die ölkrise seitdem wurde es kaum
geändert und angesichts der aktuellen
lage möchte nun aber möchten die
fraktionen nun die staatlichen kontroll
möglichkeiten noch einmal stärken das
bedeutet dass
die bundesregierung und auch die
verwaltung des staates unternehmen
stärker kontrollieren kann oliver
krischer der zuständige parlamentarische
staatssekretär erneute das
anfang der woche konnten wir berichten
dass unser bemühen uns schritt für
schritt von ris russischen energie
importen unabhängig zu machen dass wir
dabei ein gutes stück vorangekommen sind
kohle importe aus russland sind schon
deutlich reduziert der anteil von erdöl
war mal bei 35% wir sind jetzt auf dem
weg zu zwölf und der abschied von
russischem gas das waren 55 da sind wir
aktuell bei 35 das ist noch eine längere
herausforderung aber daran arbeiten wir
wir haben viele maßnahmen ergriffen
effizienzmaßnahmen sowie verbrauch zu
reduzieren wir bauen die erneuerbaren
aus wir schaffen aber auch neue
infrastruktur um unseren bezug zu
diversifizieren und wenn es gut geht
können wir schon nächste woche
vielleicht in wilhelmshaven mit dem
ersten schwimmenden mit dem bau des
ersten schwimmenden lng terminals
beginnen das sind fortschritte um sehr
konkret und sehr schnell von russischen
energielieferungen unabhängig zu werden
es sagt aber auch es zeigt aber auch wir
sind noch nicht so weit und die
unsicherheit an den energiemärkten ist
riesengroß die preise sind hoch es sind
risiken vorhanden und niemand niemand
von uns kann heute sagen wann und gegen
wen putin energieimporte als waffen
einsetzten wird wir haben das in dieser
woche im fall von polen und bulgarien
erlebt dass putin bereit ist das zu tun
aber wir werden uns nicht einschüchtern
lassen sondern unsere politik ist darauf
ausgerichtet dass wir uns für den fall
wappnen dass sich die situation zuspitzt
das zeichnet unsere politik aus meine
damen und herren
und all das ist nichts was wir uns
wünschen können wenn wir reale
versorgungsengpässe haben die haben wir
gott sei dank im moment noch nicht dann
wird das gesamtgesellschaftlich zu
enormen einschnitten führen dann reden
wir über abschaltungen von
industriezweigen dann reden wir für
folgen von nicht produktion dann reden
wir von arbeitslosigkeit da reden wir
von menschen die kein einkommen haben
die nicht zur arbeit gehen können dann
reden wir über gestörte lieferketten
dann reden wir über gestörte
versorgungsstrukturen aber je besser wir
vorbereitet sind je schneller und
umfassender wir handeln je besser können
wir auch mit der krise umgehen und
deshalb
novellieren wir jetzt das energie
sicherungs gesetz aus den 1970 er jahren
aus den zeiten der ölkrise und das ist
einfach notwendig dass wir dieses gesetz
ins 21 jahrhundert bringen denn die
regeln die dort niedergeschrieben sind
die stammen aus einer zeit da gab es
noch kein internet aber noch die
sowjetunion und ich glaube das allein
macht deutlich dass hier gehandelt
werden muss wir müssen dieses gesetz in
der aktuellen krise auf die höhe der
zeit bringen
um die wichtigsten die wichtigsten
punkte sind dabei es klingt banal aber
wir brauchen eine digitale plattform für
den bereich gas das thema gas wird in
diesem gesetz nur nicht in der
notwendigen art und weise adressiert das
ist auf erdöl zugeschnitten wir brauchen
aber jetzt eine digitale plattform wo
verbraucht und einspeisung gesteuert
werden können wo wir eingreifen können
dann wenn eine gasmenge lage eintritt um
das entsprechend managen zu können das
ist ein ganz ganz entscheidender punkt
hierfür eine rechtsgrundlage zu schaffen
wir brauchen weiterhin eine
treuhandverwaltung für unternehmen die
kritische infrastrukturen in nicht in
der weise betreiben die sie betrieben
werden müssen dass dies gefahr real ist
haben wir schon erlebt seit dem ausbruch
des krieges und deshalb ist es absolut
wichtig dass wir hier in dem gesetz
hierfür die voraus vor de rung schaffen
und ich sage auch ganz klar als ultima
ratio unter klar benannten und sehr
engen bedingungen muss auch die
enteignung möglich sein denn es kann
nicht sein dass jemand der eine
kritische infrastruktur für die
energieversorgung kritische
infrastruktur besitzt und betreibt und
diese falsch betreibt unsere
energieversorgung gefährdet auch das
regeln wir in dem gesetz wir brauchen
auch eine regelung
eine regelung zur preisanpassung meine
damen und herren denn wenn preise
kurzfristig steigern müssen lieferanten
unternehmen die weitergeben können denn
wenn sie das nicht können dann droht der
zusammenbruch von unternehmen von
energieversorgungsunternehmen unter
umständen ganze kettenreaktion und wenn
diese unternehmen dann nicht mehr da
sind dann können sie auch nicht ihren
versorgungsauftrag nachgehen auch dafür
brauchen wir klare regeln und wir
brauchen bessere regeln für die
solidarität in der europäischen union
wir arbeiten schon sehr intensiv und
sehr eng mit unseren nachbarn zusammen
aber wir wollen uns natürlich im fall
der gasmenge lage unterstützen wir
brauchen regeln dafür wie wir gemeinsam
das das schaffen können und das leistet
dieses gesetz meine damen und herren
normalerweise ist es so dass man sich
bei dem einbringen und dem beschluss
eines gesetzes wünscht dass es möglichst
oft angewendet wird ich sage dass hier
sehr deutlich wir wünschen uns dass
dieses gesetz am besten gar nicht
angewendet wird er nicht wir wissen
wir wissen
das sind starke eingriffe des staates in
den markt beim thema preise treuhand
enteignung aber wir müssen für den
handlungs ernstfall handlungsfähig sein
und die gewährleistung der
energiesicherheit
ist eine staatliche aufgabe meine damen
und herren deshalb sollte dieses gesetz
so bald wie möglich in kraft treten und
ich bitt und appelliere an sie ist zügig
und konstruktiv beraten zu beraten ich
bedanke mich jetzt schon mal für ihre
unterstützung bei diesem weg denn wir
den wir gehen zeigen wir wie
leistungsfähig effizient und stark
unsere demokratie in dieser frage ist
auch das ist unsere antwort an putin
dankeschön
oliver krischer der parlamentarische
staatssekretär
dieser gesetzentwurf wurde hier von den
fraktionen eingebracht aber es gibt
sogenannte formulierungshilfe vom
kabinett von daher spricht dann auch der
staatssekretär andreas jung jetzt für
die unionsfraktion ist
eben eine zügige und konstruktive
beratung dieses gesetzes angeraten ich
will für unsere fraktion sagen dafür
sind wir nicht nur bereits sondern es
ausdrücklich unsere position wir müssen
in dieser krise auch als antwort auf
putin
handlungsfähig sein und wir werden dafür
beitragen dass die richtigen weichen
gestellt werden
das ging
das gilt für einen ehrgeizigen zeitplan
der vorgesehen ist ja für eine
verabschiedung in der nächsten woche und
eine anhörung auf die wir wert gelegt
haben am montag in der nächsten
sitzungswoche steht dieser zügigen
beratung nicht entgegen kann aber die
qualität der beratung verbessern und
damit zeigen wir dass wir nicht nur
handlungsfähig sind sondern wir sind
auch handlungswillig als parlament und
diese dieser handlungswillig kommt auch
dadurch zum ausdruck dass wir einerseits
auch für unsere fraktion klarmachen die
regierung muss in dieser situation auch
kurzfristig handlungsmacht haben
einerseits und andererseits müssen die
wesentlichen entscheidungen vom
parlament getroffen werden in diesem
geiste werden wir die beratungen führen
auch wenn seine fraktion einbringen ist
darf ich jetzt schon prognostizieren
wird trotzdem das struck gesetz gelten
zweitens
staatssekretär krise hat angesprochen
die regelungen die hier vorgeschlagen
werden zur stärkung der europäischen
solidarität zu der bekennen wir uns
ausdrücklich und gerade in dieser woche
in der putin den gashahn für polen und
bulgarien
abgestellt hat den worten der
solidarität müssen taten der
zusammenarbeit folgen die regelungen in
diesem gesetz sind ein ausdruck davon
wir brauchen zusammenarbeit wir brauchen
zusammenhalt wir brauchen gemeinsamkeit
wir dürfen uns nicht erpressen lassen
wir dürfen uns nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen in der
europäischen gemeinschaft ist unsere